pop
[Musique]
à tanger
l'analyste
[Musique]
eh bien je suis joli garçon
en voilà une manière de me saluer pour
jour tenta de rennes bonjour c'est ainsi
que tu te présentes à présent de la
famille des malotrus focus est fou
veux-tu descendre chaque petit décent
qu'est ce que tu fais il tiendra
croyez-bien tente adrienne que ce n'est
pas sans regrets mais où vais je pensais
que je ferai des progrès aussi rapide et
que j'atteindrai aujourd'hui la salle à
manger prendre à rien mais liens qui se
moque de nous je suis aujourd'hui
victimes des proportions on peut changer
une dimension mais non un rapport de
dimension allez le premier pas est en
fait tout le reste sans suite comme qui
dirait une destinée voilà on parle
toujours des enfants et des enfants de
nos enfants mais non geste aussi ont
leur descendance
les actes s'enchaînent et nos pensées
ont leur postérité
ainsi même les vieilles filles tentes
indiennes ont une nombreuse famille
qu'elles ne peuvent pas renier
qu'est ce que c'est que ça saturne
saturne et ses anneaux qui n'accroche
pas cette saleté dans la salle à manger
ça va en comprendrait difficilement
tondez da pour une si grosse étoile
quand tu tolère ici un lampadaire
poussiéreux et des mots des célestines
célestine c'est un monde dit jacques la
fa si la mesure festival est arrivé non
regarde pas ce que c'est que cette
charte a encore un peu de ton fils j'ai
si mal combiner mon affaire que si je
peux terminer la pose de tout le système
solaire sur ses bases en tenant un conte
rigoureux et proportionnel de
l'éloignement des planètes dans le ciel
me voici contraint de prendre uranus au
plafond de sa chambre à coucher parce
que c'est un désastre
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
gens voilà quand j'ai posé à leurs
places respectives la terre et sa petite
lune dans ma chambre je ne pensais pas
l'intéressé plus tard à saturne uranus
il est plus car il ya encore à l'étude
c'est ça de toutes faites vite quelles
sont ces mesures s'élève qui vont
échouer neptune en face dans le bureau
de poste et cette bonne mademoiselle
denis qui ne s'étonnent pas de timbre et
des lettres pour chicago jura
intolérable de vivre dans le voisinage
de neptune ce jeu le paris d'avant
ségo belgo demanderont à ton frère ce
qu'il pense des tas nouvelle marotte est
rené millions je doute qu'il en pense
quelque chose
bien que cole se chauffent au soleil
comme tout un chacun le monde solaire
est un monde étranger au monde qu'il
fréquente à paris le contenu et
j'attends frères arrivent d'un moment à
l'autre il vient rarement je t'en prie
nerveux peau comme toujours avec ta
manière de voir les choses que tu il vit
à la ville moi je suis un homme de la
nature
beaucoup beaucoup vous
tu es un homme peut rien du tout je te
l'avais bien dit ce n'est pas dans une
école d'agriculture qu'on ait levé les
fermiers et dans les étables etc et
bestiaux matin soit bien du mal à dire
de ton frère toi l'état nomme d'abord il
gagne son pain toi tu le manges je mange
comme vous à la même table que vous le
même menu de la viande deux fois par
semaine et de la salade à tous les
reports et dire que tu as desgagnés
tombe à nous tourner la tête à des
filles et qu'on village on s'appelle le
bose à osaka
quant à d'heure et aux filles tu leur
parles aussi d'école bien peu vaut rien
à jeter un soir il est trop douce avec
lui un cheminement et peu à oui c'est
lui
ah ben non ça n'est pas son auto à leurs
pièces je ne sais pas la voiture s'est
arrêtée ici oui c'est pas le cas
voilà qui parle à chausey il aurait
changé d'automobiles aisa ruine ce
garçon peut-être paul ii devra t'il une
idée il a beaucoup d'idées comme les
idées ne coûteront rien n'est vrai bond
des ventes ont au contraire atteindra
une vallée ainsi les bras au vent si
j'étais amer nous aurions encore des
vaches rien pour convoyer les traire
tous les matins voici
bonjour attentes adria m merci bonjour
arrive-t-il paumé mais thibault croit
dire et penser que c'est le frère de se
voir mon pote comme on joue au foot us
boy et tu tapes art comme un chêne de
chennai et retour sont bonnes mais ne
fait bonne mine tu vois il s'est fait à
l'air de paris fait admirer ma nouvelle
voiture
enfin puisque c'est nous les riches
maintenant ou bien faire un peu de la
flac néanmoins rappelle-toi apple quand
on se croit riche on est bien près
d'être pauvre car la richesse pousse à
la dépense certes la voiture qui s'en va
oui faire une course indispensable de
chercher quelqu'un à la gare visite dont
je vais avoir à vous entretenir et ta
nouvelle guerre dardalhon levitt je te
procure g l'orgueil bien placé je ne dis
pas je fais temps à l'heure mais je
donne tant de coups de frein et quand je
roule je n'ai pas l'ambition
d'additionner des kilomètres mais de
soustraire des coups de frein si tu
avais une voiture toi tu seras joue par
le sport parce qu'à présent tu
conduirait toi même tu as voiture non
non c'est toujours joseph qui couvrait
pas cheap et un chauffeur à ne rien
faire il a trop de retenue dans la vie
on n'a pas savoir diriger ses
domestiques avec joseph et si prudent
pas la raison les domestiques coûtent
cher
font respecter j'ai besoin de quelque
chose à faire que je tourne comme est
ton rouge mais cet te voir mon pote et
moi j'avais besoin de rien sinon de m'a
fait un peu pour me dégourdir les jambes
et de toute votre attention
on vous apprend d'une grande nouvelle
qui vous étonnera sans doute sans
toutefois qu'est ce que c'est que ça
tu sais que ton frère ces passionnés
dernièrement pour les études
astronomiques et c'est un télescope à la
campagne juste de procéder campagne
voici je reconstitue le système solaire
on veut bien pénétré de sa perfection et
de sa réalité
oui le soleil et dans le jardin bon mars
et dans l'escalier et venus dans la
chambre d'amis
tu n'aura donc jamais de sérieux dans
l'esprit voilà je m'attendais à tout
sauf à ce reproche vous n'allez pas
commencé au non je ne reproche pas de me
reprocher quelque chose ça me ferait
nous nous devons de nous communiquer
dont vérité personnelle mais leur venir
me dire toi qui perds ton temps à des
balivernes
balivernes pourquoi tu ne prends pas au
sérieux j'espère en 1925 la rédaction
d'articles de publicité vantant
l'excellence d'un objet que d'une
fabrique même pas qui n'est peut-être
pas le meilleur et dont tu dit du bien
dans ce que tu es payé brandir enfin une
glacière électrique je crois donc un
objectif à la rigueur pourrait même ne
pas exister un long du trajet les gens à
comprendre que la direction de cette
publicité n'est qu'une balivernes devant
l'extraordinaire extraordinaire réalité
du système solaire
c'est que ce que j'en dirais moi que tu
as acheté de blessure électrique si
j'étais chef de publicité mas de
l'inscrire électrique que toute cette
merveilleuse machinerie automatique et
moderne conserve les aliments est pourri
les charges le si je suis touring alors
ne me rappelle pas toujours cette
différence d'âge
ça me chagrine pourquoi tu me fais
penser avec ce mot là que mon rôle dans
la vie de famille se réduit à attendre
ta mort
mon petit canton père n'avait pas encore
vendu le bois d'amour
ils étaient fermiers il hmt la famille
n'aurait pas été bon pour tes oreilles
tu te dire ces paroles sont connus le
père s'il tente en réponde de la sorte a
sonné nick ne doit pas être content de
toi ni de lui capote devrait encore y
est mon fin de rügen la peur ne va pas
souhaité qu'une seule hâte mais qu'ils
s'entendent mais si je pensais qu il
mange et on perd tout seul à une table
devant le foyer et la célestine de
mettre servir de boue les autres mangent
et après à la grande dame il quand le
père très on l'écoutait le faire
maintenant si tout n'allait pas de
travers ça devrait être pas mais on
n'écoute pas les on l'écouterait même
bien davantage s'ils n'avaient pas
changé de métier quand les avocats les
clients qui te payait devait écouter je
lui prends le temps de parler de la
profession d'avocat dans ses rapports
avec la vie de famille devant je ne suis
plus avec lui et depuis en trois ans
quelle situation de l'offre de charges
de publicité
c'est à dire quelque chose comme lampe
hiller de la veuve et de l'orphelin
bref toutes les situations inutile
grotesque ou malhonnêtes mais toi même
que fais tu nous qui es-tu l'appui base
arrière
vous n'allez toutefois vous chamailler
aujourd'hui non non non pas aujourd'hui
j'aurais même étaient heureux
avant de vous annoncer la visite que je
dois vous annoncer de m'entendre avec la
thur bien des points essentiels la torre
avec moi sur des points essentiels niro
n'eussent pas je sais que ce n'est pas
en quelques heures
crois-tu qu'avec des siècles nous y
parviendrons lyon ainsi qu'une semaine
porte quoi il retourne
et il assure déjà que nous ne serons
jamais d'accord si nous n'avions pas
sauter de notre monde dans un autre vous
seriez d'accord tous les deux vois tu
seras la charrue nuit il soit une réelle
bétail
mon frère serait encore ici à vous faire
marcher droit par à la question n'est
pas là la nouvelle que je dois annoncer
certes je ne vous chagrine rapport j'ose
même espérer au contraire mais vous
enveloppera sans doute d'un sentiment de
solitude dans les plaidoiries tu disais
de telle bourde
oui vous enveloppent paix avec de la
solitude c'est assez cocasse deux
acteurs sont impossibles sans coeur et
qui ne respectent rien bien je crois la
venue de nous mettre d'accord sur les
points essentiels
chaque nous entendrions mieux si tu
aurais le sens de tes responsabilités et
dites nous quelle est cette nouvelle
pole mais il m'a t on chaque fois et je
voudrais vous dire avec des bouts de
quelle réussite dans la vie dedans de
cette assurance agressive
la fréquentation des as à à la vue
singulière que nous avons méfie toi
jacques attali de mauvaises
fréquentations à paris oui j'ai reçu
dernièrement la visite d'anne tes amis
de paris il me croyais encore avocats et
ne sachant ton frère va me trouver
il avait commis quelques sottise il le
trendnet en correctionnelle je n'ai pas
de préjugés
lorsque la postérité il choisira parmi
nos héros c'est ses gloires et bien je
serai bien content de voir que certains
jeunes seront peut-être pris par toi
comme des condamnés au fond dont tu
aurais profondément honte j'en suis
presque persuadé pense évidemment à
socrate à itunes de l'est et au
chevalier de la barre et même au au
marquis de sade
donc nous a révoltés
[Musique]
belle journée d'automne
ben tu ne songe pas comme un homme
raisonnable à te créer un foyer
non alors là mon vieux franchement pas
du tout dans les circonstances actuelles
est en rapport avec que la nouvelle que
je peux vous annoncer je m'en réjouis
si ils relancent en remises aux armes en
attaque créer un foyer tueur est ainsi
avec moment et dante adrian mais d'un
point de vue plus général je le regrette
quant à la conduite ultérieure de ta vie
sans doute pour être à la mode des fous
qui te servent de camarades ne crois tu
pas à l'amour non plus je ne dirai
peut-être pas si bêtement et les filles
qui t'attend de la nuit prozac
elles sont charmants certains l'autre
soir j'ai demandé au curé s'il
regrettait d'être célibataire mais
puisqu'il m'a répondu lui qui connaît
les secrets des donzelles chères
demoiselles et les curés sont consolés
de n'être pas marquer quand ils
entendent les femmes s'est confessé
par toutes les femmes n'attendent pas
tout les ans simon devaient toutes les
femmes sans exception non ferme et et à
la conversation nous en plaine lundi ce
que tu veux dire
et bien voilà j'ai très grande nouvelle
à vous annoncer
bonjour et mais j'aurais aimé ou
l'annoncé avec un truc de cérémonie mais
je n'ai pas enfin j'ai perdu
suffisamment de temps sur la route
d'abord oui ma voiture a crevé deux fois
et avec mon frère en discussion
sterizone oui oui oui stérile et je le
regrette wes
maman tente adrienne oui aussi jacques
j'ai le bonheur de vous annoncer
c'est une nouvelle grave
quoi que je vais fonder une famille
fonder une famille j'aurais aimé vous
annoncer cette nouvelle avec plus de
solennité
mais quelle nouvelle qu'elle seule a été
je vais marnier petit mari avec qui
et bien voilà ma fiancée arrive tu t'es
pris en six ans nous le dira
de passe exactement puisque je l'espère
ce soir célébrer mes fiançailles avec
votre assentiment de six soirs comme ça
joseph le chauffeur est parti à la gare
chercher ma fiancée qui arrivent par le
rapide de paris il n'aurait pas été
convenable que nous voyagions ans en a
déjà mais la maison qui n'est pas rangé
je sais de quelle importance et 7h dans
ma vie et je serais heureux que tout le
monde autour de moi
l'esprit est assez sérieux pour
comprendre la solennité de cet événement
tu es chef de publicité
tu as encore raté sa vocation en tant
que te faire chef du protocole ou maître
de cérémonie à quelle belle phrase nous
allons
or pour l'enterrement de ta vie de
pierre 604 achats ouija j'espère que tu
seras te tenir d'une manière convenable
le jour où je te présente celle que
j'associe à mon avenir
il me serait agréable de devoir mettre
un peu de dignité ne serait ce que dans
ton maître décès dans ces conditions je
vais me composé un matière digne c'est
un figure de farceurs qui atterrit
drôlerie dans mon père et l'âge de 20
ans l'imposer à tout le monde et à lui
même lui a en fait eu quelques morts un
homme qui ne commande pas c'est un valet
de ferme c'est notre argent qu'ils ne
seraient jamais qu'un valet de ferme non
tentées rainbow parole me transforme je
vais vous prouver dès aujourd'hui ma
volonté de devenir digne de la famille
nous en jugeront il me semble déjà que
la barbe de tous au menton oui
mademoiselle du ciblons des n'étant pas
dans la voiture déjà et je ne vous ai
rien dit de faux panneaux montel par jeu
tour à chercher voilà des manières je
vais me préparer
voilà trop de sérieux pour s'être
laissés engluer par une créature mal il
me semble que cette demoiselle puisse
faire accompagner par sa mère ou son
père sûrement qu'elle va rester à dîner
si ce soir le calme bas célestine
s'est-elle j'espère qu'ils étaient mus
nous n'avons pas nous asseoir et attend
c'est toi
très vite comprendre que chez l'émir non
étrangère n'a jamais commandé
je le sais adrienne enfin tout de même
ne soit pas trop elle fera comme moi
elle deviendra une mirman et un jour
peut-être plus tard elle est bien lancé
deux jeunes personnes l'épaule qui
laissait rien si les mêmes dans ces
lettres
je vous présente ma demoiselle du
ciblant d'elle dont je vous ai parlé
voici ma mère aussi
je suis très heureuse de vous connaître
mademoiselle est bien et vu aussi bon
mon fils m'a dit tout ce que j'ai je ne
doute pas que mes os mais j'y pense vous
allez rester ce soir à dîner avec nous
et étant adrienne
je vous salue mademoiselle
nous aimons beaucoup pas le quai tout le
portrait de mon frère qui fils aîné et
le chef de toute notre famille on a fait
un homme loyal n'est pas un parisien
comme au parisien lui il est chez nous
c'est pas parisien qui a été élevé ici
mademoiselle j'ai été élevé à la
campagne aussi je suis bien aise
d'apprendre que votre père est fermier
non non non son père a été appelé très
tôt à paris par ses occupations
mais on offre dans une chaise pour la ta
fiancée
marie marie que fait-on m'arrive
vous prendrez bien un peu de vin bouchée
des biscuits à la cuiller volontiers
vous êtes très aimable
et où comptes tu faire habiter taf apple
quand vous serez marqué 22 soit ma chère
tante que si je me marie c'est pour
revivre avec ma femme nous habitons
ensemble à paris mais sans en manquer
une nous passerons toutes nos vacances
ici mais quand tu seras à ton travail
que fera mademoiselle la longueur de
journée seuls à paris c'est une
situation de nos jours dans votre pari
pour une femme que d'être seul à courir
les rues il est vrai que vous nous aurez
naturellement des enfants mais paul j'y
pense il faudra mener ta famille ici
avec les enfants car mademoiselle les
enfants de notre race son besoin de
respirer notre ère pour bien de venir
vous êtes très aimable de ma vie tu es
déjà mes enfants et moi ne me remerciez
pas
pas les toucher lui ses enfants seront
ici chez eux
voilà voilà un exemple que je ne vous
conseille pas quand on a des domestiques
c'est pour qu'il vous servent
je n'ai pas trouvé marie moment et
voudrais-tu conduire manu en selle
blondel à sa chambre dont j'ai enfin
dans une chambre enfin celle que tu lui
destine pour cette nuit la poussière de
la route
la chambre bleue n'est ce pas je vous
dérange vous voulez vous bien me faire
ma petite lucie est ce que vous n'êtes
pas déjà un peu chez vous je vais vous
le portez je défends bien
mon garçon je te félicite ou pas
ne la trouvais pas joli à peine car de
telles que tu dis oui elle ne pouvait
pas attendre qu'on lui offre sa chambre
la poussière de la route
cette manière de défendre porter mes
bagarres je vous défends je formule de
politesse
elle est mauvaise soit l'équivalent de
je vous prie de n'en rien faire il n'a
rien à défendre
je croyais que tu tenais de ton père
enfin des boosts la bouteille puisque tu
aime recevoir les ordres à présent
tout s'arrangera très bien vous verrez
tente abriel ou la tétanie chez des amis
il ya longtemps
oui presque un an c'est tout en somme tu
ne sais pas qui c'est et sa famille tu
comptes nous la présenter le jour des
noces non dès que cela sera possible
mais non je n'épouse pas la famille
j'espère bien elle me semble avoir déjà
suffisamment de tests seuls 9 à 10 3 me
bush enfin je ne veux pas d'infliger un
garçon d'ailleurs j'attends beaucoup de
ses relations avec vous ma tante lucie
sa jeunesse à un peu trop de propension
à une légèreté à une légèreté spirituel
dû à l'ambiance générale de notre époque
sa visite ont lieu de notre famille lui
donnera un point d'appui s'incorpore à
aux générations des murmures vous verrez
les faussaires de cousine jeanne
ah oui oui oui oui peut-être un peu le
mentor les yeux aussi tu ne trouves pas
paul jeu si peu connue cousine jeanne
était est en communion avec la nièce
agathe
tu te souviens qu'il voulait marier ce
petit couple est gêné les gilbert est
bas les a mariés ils ont maintenant des
enfants les cousines jeannette m arrête
de l'est et l'aîné a déjà communiqué
communier communaux mais je pense plus
les pères de familles achètent pas si tu
l'as eu maintenant ténébreux n'a
d'ailleurs la nièce à gars là à gauche
du grand père mais elle est encore jaoui
enfin sur la photo qui est viennent
hélas ma nièce agathe est morte voilà
plus de cinq ans
un bien brave homme donc le florentin
et ça je qu'est ce que c'est que ça
l'histoire travail de mon frère mais
mais que fait-on jamais mazel doit avoir
soif un peu de vin rouge ne vous effraie
pas lucie zèle en trinquet à votre
bonheur mes enfants mais que fait-on
jacques j'ai hâte de vous présenter mon
frère corey haim décédé inconvenance ne
devrait-il pas être ici jacques est bien
jacques fait-il donc nous t'attendons
cha li 6 vous entrez s'il est retenu
retenu retenu retenu à quoi pas un
exemple mademoiselle bien qu'il soit un
milliard mans pourtant rosen exemple
nous pouvons tout de même pas portée
dans la maison familiale sans lui le
premier poste à notre avenir
voyons jacques jack
j'arrive à voici voici ma chère russie
je vais avoir le plaisir
c'est avec l'assentiment familiale
l'enceinte du confrère on nous oublie
toujours dit que la maison c'est être à
tête d'excusés d'excuser les
dérèglements 3 tout le temps je vous
prie d'excuser les violences d'un frère
qui en un jour si grave et après l'avoir
donné une si belle leçon de maintien
mans est à ce point de calme et de
dignité ne des mascarades aujourd'hui et
sauvage cher future belle-soeur la festo
pignon que vous aurez du respect de
votre mère il connaît bien cette
imminente mais c'est pour se moquer vous
savez les lucistes sa barbe est fausse
[Rires]
maudite si je m'attendais bon j'accepte
votre reer avec humilité mais je dois à
tous les professions publié du top plus
un mot parce que tu n'as pas qualité sa
misérable je préfère me retirer l'eau
voilà qui ne me donne pas envie de
rester dans adrienne toi tu vas sortir
immédiatement de cette pièce de tout de
cette maison moi en tant que chef de
famille je t'interdis désormais à long
terme et noir et il a voulu moutran je
ne demande pas comme moi en tout cas je
ne veux pas vous faire chier à cause de
moi c'est ça c'est ça maintenant
commander france se sort à ça je sors je
préfère me
mais l'étoile fulton vous emballez pas
je vous avais jamais vu en colère ne
mauvais départ lucie comprenez vous les
voulez c'est un instant seul avec votre
frère je suis certaine de m'entendre
avec lio ou seriez trop bonne mais aussi
de vous intéresser un esprit fort tu
n'es qu'un d'ici là je vais vous
réconcilier tous les deux ça sera notre
souvenir de fiançailles mais oui mais
oui mon petit poney demoiselle est calme
et douce vient tout s'arrangera tueur
est parue lundi dans douze ce soir
gaiement à moins de votre frère affiche
des ventes en hausse et retenons ce sera
la deuxième leçon de la journée lewis
vient pas bien
nous nous occupons du dîner tous les
deux et puis aussi de tentes adrienne
balayer nous est trop bonne
l'uci
je remarque que sans jalousie que l'on
rend justice tandis que mes efforts à
moi sont méconnus on est votre barque je
vois quoi vous ressemblez cousinage je
le sentais mon frère je suis mon frère
je suis l'esprit de famille le sérieux
de la maison la sagesse des idées et le
bonheur dans la vie cela réuni avec
votre retard oui et aussi le désir de
cultiver les joies domestique une main
sur le berceau du dernier ni sur la
canne du grand père mais vous êtes lancé
lorsque je vous présente un motif
allégorique que je sculpte ray
d'ailleurs un de ces jours
vous êtes sculpteur non mais je vais le
devenir et nous serons tous ici le soir
sous la langue le jour sous l'oeil de
tentes adrienne vous tricotant mois
sculptant mon frère nous bénisse ans
tandis que des hommes inconnus nous
apporterons matin et soir le boire et le
manger
quel homme inconnu la maison est hantée
non n'ayez - tant de fantaisie calzone
inconnu ignorez vous que nous avons des
actions de bonnes actions ce qui nous
dispense d'enfer et qu'à travers le
monde dans des usines diverses des
sommes que nous ne connaissons pas
travailler chaque jour quelques secondes
pour nous si bien qu'on pourrait
récolter du matin au soir sans que votre
assiduité en soit troublé pourquoi vous
payez vous a si ma tête
j'avoue que paul m'avait décrit tout
autrement son frère je croyais et
vaguement cultivateurs et j'espérais me
promenais avec vous à cheval dans les
chemins vous aimez le cheval au oui je
suis jamais monté à cheval ses doigts
d'être si un taux 10 ans et je me
faisais une fête de courir avec vous
dans les rangs voilà donc quels sont vos
pensées au lieu de préparer la réponse
au discours que mon frère prononcera ce
soir avant le cidre bouché
palm a prononcé un discours à qui à la
solennité de la cérémonie devant ça mais
et sa chère tante devant vous même et
moi je suis là vous êtes certain les
discours
avant bon alors a déjà pu se retenir
devons faire des discours ou connaissez
donc de ce matin n'ont jusqu'à l'épaule
depuis
et puis enlevez votre barbe non oui je
les garçons dites moi vous espériez mais
c'est au mcee rouge pensez pas à vous je
ne vous connaissais pas je le savais
seulement que vous avez été choisi par
mois
j'ai été choisi j'ai été choisi je sais
pas si le petit chat c'est vous qui
l'avez distinguer vous ment beatty et
vous l'aviez jamais vu en colère
cette vision aura moins fier de votre
choix
ainsi vous n'aimez pas beaucoup votre
frère il est un peu sur la neige pour
moi journée ils m'aiment bien sûr une
même mais parce que je suis son frère je
représente sa dignité fraternelle comme
il aimera en bout sans état de marie
nous serait pour lui le miroir où ils se
regardent à vivre marie je ne vois très
bien se mirer dans vos yeux pour
arranger sa cravate ou jean marie ainsi
détestant votre frère car vous le
détestez vous avez imaginé cette petite
blague afin de dérouter sa fiancée effet
raté son mariage
je n'imaginais pas que mon frère que ce
délicieux autre chose qu'une d'un
nouveau maire philippe mais votre
manigances market chic tout de même à
l'époque jugez vous aussi dans cette
maison au pass audace juger les accusés
trois un truc employés pour faire des
compliments à soi même
je ne dis pas ça pour vous vous êtes
très chic
mais mon dieu c'est ma part vous a fait
rire que chez vous ici comment qu'est ce
que je fais ici
n'allez pas vous imaginer que j'ai
trouvé votre président très spirituel
excusez moi naturellement que des
excuses mais pourquoi avez vous imaginé
cette comédie
est ce parce que la vie est impossible
tiens voici vous verrez quand ils disent
les miremont si c'est de la rigolade
évidemment cette trêve ne mène à rien
mais elle occupe alors pourquoi didier
vous ici c'est tout ce que vous avez
comme occupation
oui et bien je vous félicite j'avais
mieux à offrir
c'est une pression des pâtes la
fainéantise et une brillante règles et
de vie est ce ma faute si rien est assez
solide pour que j'accroche une ambition
sans doute démesuré
vous avez de ses grandes ambitions en
tout cas les satisfactions des autres ne
me satisfont pas la maison jamais vu mon
frère est avancé bureau de paris si
quelquefois souvent même mois une fois
un jour qui m'avait convoqué pour ce
faire admirer il vous croyez qu'on peut
prendre au sérieux ce cataclysme le
téléphone de machines à écrire des
sottises et cette atmosphère si numen
des bureaux que même les fleurs les
fleurs qu'on pose sur la table du patron
printanière d'esclaves soumise deux
femmes vendues c'est un poème chic mais
vous êtes fous la porte je vois que je
ne le reverrai plus je vais chercher
quoi aussi juste ça mais je ne cherche
pas ou partez vous
pourquoi vous retenez vous de pleurer
mois hélas la femme qui me frappe leur n
est pas encore là vous ne valait même
pas votre frère même pas ce que je vais
dire c'est que votre frère a déjà pleuré
pour des femmes lui au moins pour une
femme
vous vous avez fait pleurer paul vous
c'est une blague thomas plantive dans
quelle tenue dans quelle attitude
devrait l'art il était à genoux eh bien
chers amis vous ne connaissez pas paul
ou bien peut-être connaissez-vous pas il
mais vous ne connaissez pas monsieur car
non là je ne demandais pas seulement
pour moi mais aussi pour ne pas pouvoir
devenir même miremont pour la vie pour
la vie naturellement trop tôt dit ainsi
pour la vie de la gorge se serre mais la
règle est la même pour tout le monde on
se marie pour la vie je me le disent pas
je regrette de n'être pas parti
hier je ne voudrais jamais jamais je
veux voir ce qu'on leur a fait de vous
et que deviendrez vous vous même
je ne sais pas je veux savoir où j'entre
pour toujours fixé dans cette famille
que vous partiez vous au hasard
non non non vous êtes curieuse de
l'avenir des gens que vous rencontrez
quand vous rencontrez un homme vous le
regardez en pensant tout ça est très
joli mais dans des embryons
imaginons dans dix ans oui que ce qu'on
nous dans dix ans voilà je ne sais pas
quand est ce que vous le laissez vous ne
savez rien dit oui je le sais t&d de
matériel vous révélera les premiers
secrets de famille
commentant baptise en arrière de la
bonne la bouteille d'eau de javel afin
qu'elles ne brûlent pas le linge elle
vous apprendra que le samedi pour les
cuirs lamarthe people vous parlera avec
de grands noms des liens sacrés du
mariage ne vous a pas déjà fait de
grands discours sur l'assurance que
d'autres dans la vie une famille unie et
puissante
vous ne perdez rien pour attendre notre
frère je ne peux tout de même pas vous
dire vous ne savez rien mais maintenant
mon frère a pu consentir vous amener ici
subitement et sans plus d'apparat sans
réception à la guerre
non je ne suis pas venu par le trait
mais en auto avec lui
on avait pris elle me taire voyez c'est
impossible
vous parlez vous parlez vous ne pensez
qu'à vous et vous m'avez pas regarder
vous n'avez pas écouté
vous savez pas qui je suis qui est de
nous et je sais pas je vous en supplie
ça c'est pas de ciment vous aurez
jusqu'à votre dernier battements de
coeur pour le contempler aller chercher
paul je ne veux pas que vous partiez je
veux que vous allez cherchez pas je vais
et partez vous infligez pas je ne suis
pas à plaire je ne ne tient à rien nous
demandiez tout à l'heure quelles étaient
mes dernière occupation
tenez regardez qu'est ce que c'est une
étoile et pas même visible à l'oeil nu
j'ai vécu des mois dans ces mondes
désert qu'il me rendais tolérable ma
solitude elle cherchait pas
alors dites-moi quand vous étiez petite
fille à quoi rêviez vous n'avez pas une
photographie prise sur une plage c'est
ce que vous attendiez de pinces charland
je ne rêvais pas après ce charmant aqua
rêviez-vous pas ce que j'allais devenir
tout simplement
madame miremont quel pays je connaîtrai
domaine de miremont ce grand vide dans
lequel ma vie s'organiserait la salle à
manger de miremont je pouvais voir un
homme sans trembler est ce lui me disait
je n'ai encore rien pour moi qui va
devenir tout ne tremblez plus madame
miremont taisez vous taisez vous pensé
quand une porte s'ouvre devant moi je me
demande mon dieu qui va entrer j'attends
toujours des miracles
oui c'est un mois mois mais miracle
c'est ce qui arrive et que je
n'attendais pas et qui me surprend alors
est impossible que ma vie soit des
imprévus ici ma présence en raku voilà
l'irak
lester et vous avez vous une femme
bisous nord où avez vous vécu d'où venez
vous je viens de mai à temps vous
comprenez
voilà mon pays et la famille que
j'abandonne mes 20 ans je vais un jour
en finir et un jouet l'homme derely et
bien vous êtes courageuse 6/4 vous
détruit en connaissance de cause ici on
ne trompe pas vous êtes prévenus à
l'entrée tenez regardez dans les
accessoires de la maison voici le
fauteuil de laguiole j'ai vu mon grand
père assis monfils alors retour du
régiment c'est reposeront mes fils
soldat dans une famille comme les
générations se mêlent vite de quelle
façon ils jonglent avec les mariages les
baptêmes et les enterrements à les
regarder les portraits des ancêtres les
tableaux de la famille tente adrienne
bbc le mariage
deux mamans allaitantes abriel à votre
âge et au dessus si vous permettez voici
la place pour accrocher votre portrait
de première communion
oui ne pensait pas qu'elle jaunir est
ici la photo de vos dix ans et ici on
vous accrochera avec un petit chignon
puis en cheveux blancs canton cimetière
il est à côté nous avons un caveau de
famille perpétuité
c'est seulement aujourd'hui que le
désespoir ont fait sangloter auprès de
ces pauvres chose manquait voyez vous je
vois ce que d'autres peut-être ne voit
pas à mon âge c'est que les plus de 50
ans on tue 20 ans est aussi et que nous
ne le croyons pas et nous serons un jour
qu'à me si nous vivons comme voilà ce
que j'appelle la vie de famille
c'est cette vie au millionnaire actes et
des ben ali mais les musées crise eu
peur
comme ses petits
voici votre chaise et les trois autres
mettez vous ici voilà il n'y a personne
mais en êtes-vous bien incertaine moi je
vous vois tous les quatre à l'ère aulas
tente adrienne et vous c'est l'heure du
potage et taisez vous votre vie commence
alors moi je pars parce que trop de
choses dans le monde pour rester ici en
fermier du jacques rester c'est moi moi
tout part oui je m'en vais rester et
vous leur dirait paul parce que vous
savez pas ce qu'ils pensent de moi
pokora tout autre chose mais tant pis je
ne peux pas je vais pas partir ainsi
tout de suite quand je serai loin très
loin rester pour lui dire quoi vous dire
à part que je ne peux pas que je ne peux
pas je ne peux pas j'ai compris tout de
suite en entrant mais oui ce n'est pas
vous tout de suite j'ai senti que
j'étais perdu j'ai essayé mais je me
sens déjà mourir je veux vivre
mais si je n'allais pas partir à 6me si
l'uci
[Applaudissements]
il est 11 heures bientôt nous allons
vivre sans voir le soleil nous
coucherons jusqu'à l'aube pour nous le
verrons crépuscule d'abord lever vous
tirant un temps de ma petite prière
quotidienne choix fait et je vais te
sortir du lit moi oui mon crayon voilà
s'il découvre ça chante croit il ne
comprendra pas je l'expliquerai rien
port dont mon vieux soleil devoir
manquer des heures de bonheur pendant
que tu éclairait déjà le monde mais je
suis si heureuse tu si je suis heureuse
même quand je dors musique oui tu as
déjà commencé notre nouvelle journée
mais comme tous les autres jours je la
marquerait pour bien la saisir au
passage nouvelle petite barre droite de
haut en bas
c 'est mais que peux-tu biens fabriqués
à culture physique quelle heure est il
11 heures ah si j'ai bonne mémoire nous
n'avons pas un sou et astor là je
devrais être au journal oui bah je vais
me recoucher piste atteint
qui sait comment ce soir le bar est
cette croix mais quoi qu'il arrive je te
remercierai toujours de ses 172 jours de
bonheur oui heureusement que nous sommes
pas obligés d'y devant les autres avec
mes pensées nul sinon il rire est tous à
découvrir que je suis pas encore habitué
à ma chance qu'est ce que c'est mais
vous en avez tous paix il est tout de
même 11 heures c'est moi un vieux max et
tu viens [ __ ]
bon sang qu'est ce que je fous trouvait
à je vois tu ne le sais pas combien la
race et toi là tu réfléchis tu me le
dire à tout à l'heure
quelle maison jacques les avec les gens
de rose c'est assommant pour les autres
et ça n'existe pas les autres yaël y
avoir il ya nous unit à rien et puis y'a
bien l'amérique la chine
la pologne sur le danube lincendie de
vaugirard jacques y ait le feu avant
jura et bien voir quoi une usine de
l'empirique bon dieu bah ouais ou et
voilà mon deuxième ratage en quinze
jours ils vont vider
je veux pousser mais idiot sitôt 243 sur
javel alors du moment que le quartier
jamel ne brûle pas tout le quartier de
grenelle comprenez moi ça m'est
complètement égal ce n est pas mon
travail tu comprends gros malin occupe
toi de tes affaires allaient toutes les
veines l'eau pour vous régaler
laisse-moi m'habiller tranquille dit le
journal écoeurant
donc j'ai aux maths bonjour l'uci attend
comme ça mon vieux ici
et puis embrassez-moi sur les jours oh
non non non je vous dirais bonjour le 6
mai pour les joues ce qu'il a fait est
un homme qu'on n'aime pas ce que ça peu
être méchant nguema notre homme alors je
vous ai très méchante je dit pas si fort
que vous aimez jacques je finirai
parfois le croire
j'en serais plus heureux je comprends
parfaitement votre amour pour jacques
moi même je trouve un type épatant et je
peux même vous n'aimerez pas votre vie
entière
pourtant si je meurs de maja corps a été
seul l'amour de ma vie même si je me
rate vous m'agacer avez vos questions
idiotes
vous comprenez pas ce que je vais vous
dire mais si très bien mais non
avez-vous la tension et tout est là avez
vous l'intention de ne plus jamais vous
déshabiller devant un autre homme
et je dis déshabiller par un vieux
restes de scrupules kerbala choix qui
correspond d'ailleurs à quelque chose
les femmes hésitent un peu à vous
habiller de lanthanum et après
n'hésitent plus devant rien je ne vous
dirais plus un mot vous voulez pas vous
répondre parce que vous ne voulez pas
vous interrogez d'abord croyez vous à la
fidélité éternelle de jal
taisez vous jacques supporte que vous
passiez la cour mais tout de même
alors ta réfléchi quoi aux raisons
profondes de ta présence ici je viens
déjeuner quoi tout vient déjeuner eh ben
mon vieux t'as pas de chance pas de
temps et ben oui parce que notre cher
ami bientôt si des jeunes et puis c'est
tout comment ça c'est nous serons tous
les quatre seuls tu ne comprends pas
seul avec notre appétit et des assiettes
vides et vous avez pas vous aussi
oui alors l'amour nous avons tous une
faim de loup
oui oui je suis dans les gares dans la
peau d'un an dans nos portefeuilles
tu vois ce propriétaire il a de l'argent
il le cache
je n'ai pas d'argent rends moi mon
portefeuille j'ai eu la même chance ou
au pardon je ne la connaissais pas ces
charmantes ici une photo vous avez vous
parlé ça c'est toi qui la lui a donnée
mais non ce n'est pas moi bon bah il a
bien le droit d'avoir sa photo dans sa
poche
vraiment eh bien je regrette un peu la
gabarre donné les femmes sont insensées
elle s'efforce de trouver intolérable eu
l'idée que tu as dans ton portefeuille
d'une petite image d'elle elle trouve
tout à fait normal de se montrer à toi
tous les jours en chair et en os et un
mètre de distance mais en ce moment ils
te regardes et tu es beaucoup plus
ressemblante que certains photographient
et c'est beaucoup plus grave en fassions
considère comme grave fait contre garder
même
quoi donc avez-vous pour la 50e fois de
frapper avant d'entrer au ma chair lui
si vous êtes victime d'une éducation
périmés et d' habitude ancestrale que
vous prenez pour des convictions
philosophiques
nous sommes chez nous nulle part chers
amis
oui vous avez de l'argent aux jeux
méprise l'argent c'est pour déjeuner
alors moi je dispose de très peu je
crois de 2 francs 15 morts et moi de 3
francs et cette soupe est bonne alors
oui non si la pauvreté il reste du
beurre un peu de caviar on fera des
toasts et du thé je téléphone au journal
j'achète du pain et je reviens tu
devrais déjà être parti pour est déjà
revenu l'embrassement nom et aux dealers
tout de même à ton journal qu'à paris on
ne pète pas assez les journalistes
permettez je suis tu dire votre propre
et adorable retour remous cas d'orage il
y connaît rien comme toi tu connait
quelque chose oui et quand même de dire
que c'est la robe que l'uci avait hier
soir la même robe transformer c'est vrai
n'est pas fini de transformer regarder
tout ce qu'on peut faire avec une robe
regardent peut-être ainsi qu'à ceux ci
antonio est regardé comme 7,5 change un
peu les airs bon qui sait ça a au
couturier mon vieux à couturier des
champs elysées oui je connais enfin je
connais de nom alors tu veux faire de
notre amie une femme à la mode quoi oui
hymne aux femmes de notre époque un
mannequin vous savez dessinée peut-être
je ne sais pas pourquoi j'ai un ami qui
travaille à la comptabilité cherbourg et
à la maip avec les femmes qui font des
modèles qui inventent qui dessinent
gagnent jusqu'à cent mille francs par an
tourner sans me faut pour quoi faire
si vous avez raison je vais vivre toute
la journée avec ce biais
je vais être heureux ah oui ça je savais
que vous vous contentiez de peu vous ne
comprenez pas c'est pas cette mirifique
situation qui peut me tente et même une
seconde mais l'idée celle du changement
d'existence vous êtes malheureusement
d'existence actuelle vous savez bien que
non
possible mais ça ne durera pas quel
charmant garçon délicats ou non je ne
suis ni charmant ni délicat ni danseur
mondain et j'essaie de comprendre
seulement voilà et je vous dis si vous
teniez à entrer dans la famille de
jacques vous vous êtes trompé deux
frères fallait prendre l'autre mais vous
êtes fous un certain paul un homme tout
à fait dans votre genre de femme qui
s'installe dans le bonheur
je les ai vu une fois mais une fois
qu'ils comptent jacques à ce moment là
avait déjà fait sa fugue sa petite fugue
avec vous 1 il est rené de la campagne
avec vous avez connu paul et oui j'avais
un différend avec un libraire qui
croyait m'avoir vu emporté quelques-uns
de ses livres sans le prévenir
alors voulant que mes démêlés avec ce
libraire vindicatif ne fuse de quelque
utilité jeu profitait de l'aubaine pour
faire la connaissance de paul à a le
gros malin fit semblant d'écouter mon
histoire et s'y intéresser trop content
qu'il était de pouvoir faire la
connaissance d'un ami de son frère dans
une situation qu'il juge est
incompatible avec la bonne marche du
commerce
je savais moi qu'il n'était plus inscrit
au barreau mais lui lui il n'y aurait
que mon unique désir était de le voir
dans l'exercice de sa morale d'homme
tranquille je ne vois pas de rapport
entre vos disques où est ma destinée
s'il vous est celle du frère djaoui tout
comme vous il ne comprit pas mes
discours lorsque je lui exposaient les
dangers de toutes les conquêtes la
vanité de toutes les possessions
je possède quoi chez remy jacques que
vous tenez par la main comme un sergent
de ville qui est un voleur mais c'est
pas vrai hier il peut attendait qu'il
n'y avait qu'une seule femme libre dans
tout notre groupe et que ça à mon pardon
j'ai dit que l'uci avait un tempérament
de feu
libre et que seul l'avenir nous dira est
vous croyez toujours à minuit dans une
table de café lorsqu'on dit n'importe
quoi
histoire de ne pas rentrer chez soi oui
oui c'est vrai je dis n'importe quoi
pour m'entourer de toutes les
possibilités
je ne veux rien posséder même pas ma
pensée je la laisse libre elle aussi
j'ai hâte de le boire ton roman car pour
un psychologue des cocasse
ah oui alors si je suis un psychologue
si cocasse comment expliques tu que je
sache pourquoi tu seras toujours
amoureux de la femme de ton meilleur ami
mais ce n'est pas par canaillerie comme
on pourrait le penser qu'il n'a jamais
eu d'autre désir que de coucher avec la
femme de son meilleur ami
quelle que soit la femme et quelle que
soit la mise non c'est vous au contraire
c'est même le trait le plus noble de sa
pauvre la thur il aime tellement son ami
il prend cette île ses goûts y compris
sa femme à tous trois un séducteur tués
a séduit c'est simple si tu mens croyais
elle tu saurais que tes sentiments
prennent un détour inutile
voyons et que ton véritable destin est
d'être pédéraste à bord et aux hyérois
je suis si vous saviez à quel point ils
leur enseigneront à huy dans la lah il
veut dire mais ils n'osent pas que
j'écoute aux portes
on va pas vous le saviez ma belle amie
c'est une habitude que me rapproche les
gens qui n'ont pas la violence de mes
curiosités
alors ce crétin fait donc allusion à ce
petit détail que je sais de vous ce que
je ne m'explique pas jacques est
paraît-il votre premier amour
pourquoi le sursauter pas ainsi pas les
femmes sont déconcertantes
elle se marie avec fleur d'oranger
convoque toutes leurs familles pour la
première nuit où elles vont faire
l'amour sans être gêné le moins du monde
parce que moi à moi je sais six mois
après que la première fois c'est avec
joie ses débuts est ce que ça vous
regarde donner à ce titre de se faire
appeler des noms si prétentieux que le
vôtre
voilà pseudonyme chers amis si vous
trouvez que chers amis soit un nom
extraordinaire c'est dans le choix de ce
nom une manifestation de votre modestie
vous avez fait tendre que je sers à mi
temps discret du scrabble nous c'est
désormais mon étiquette est d'abord allé
très suffisante pour paris chers amis
chers amis on reconnaissait que j'ai
assez bien la ligue ans c'est mon
affaire
plus de familles plus d'état civil j'ai
tout détruit sa famille avec on
reconnaît que j'ai profondément détruit
en moi tout esprit de famille non lui si
jacques se méprend lorsqu ils
s'imaginent que vous êtes affranchi de
tout ses bons petits préjugés qui font
le bonheur des sociétés et le malheur
des hommes et âmes sensibles à l'heureux
au 1 jour vous apprendrez ils sont
malheureux ceux qui attendent leur
bonheur de leur désir de posséder et
d'atterrir
car on ne peut rien posséder régate ne
peut être acquis les choses de ce monde
sont encore plus fragiles que le bonheur
des hommes et il faut vivre les mains
ouvertes pour tous recevoir et pour tous
peur vous êtes un poème m'avait dit
monsieur paul non non non non je suis un
riche profond orgueilleux pour se
contenter de la richesse et tu sais
résignés à vivre dans un monde charmant
n'ont rien et à moi où tout est à moi
même les livres des libraires à jack
lucie demandé à l'instant si les hommes
étaient malheureux tour mon chéri c'est
sale égoïste emballant mais moi j'ai le
courage de mes désirs il ne reproche
tous d'habiter ici je suis venu par
hasard c'est entendu mais si je reste
c'est parce qu'il n'ya vraiment pas de
raison pour je parle puisque jacques
même et que je laime tant que cela
durera pourquoi voulez vous que nos
questions les buts et moi j'ai une
nouvelle à vous annoncer
oui mais il ne faut pas pleurer ma
petite lucie
voilà tu vas me quitter oui mais je ne
vais pas aux ormes écoute mais sera
terminée je parle c'est entendu mais je
pars aux quinze jours seulement
tu pars pour 15 jours pourquoi à coups
de téléphone au journal
très bonne nouvelle pologne première
classe grosse galette reportage
sensationnel sur la question juive
jacques miremont ils ont choisi jacques
me normand sensationnel et une en
pologne je ne peux pas l'administrateur
de père est certainement pas ton voyage
et le directeur situe m'accompagnait
trouverez à coup sûr mon reportage bâclé
nous vivons au milieu de conventions
solide
c'est peu dire quelque chose de très
bien et sans le montrer en dessous
animés d'un esprit révolutionnaire ce
qui est très utile dans un journal
bourgeois bientôt avec moi alors portage
sur l'armée polonaise cherchent un
titulaire mais le journal personne ne
comprend le top 6 la rester correcteurs
chers amis de signer une oeuvre
bouleversant les habitudes des hommes
mais ce que tu vois ce nom au bas d'une
série d'articles non jeunes
déshonorerait il ya des noms difficiles
à porter au rock culot hier ils me
disaient le contraire et c'est parce que
la vérité que je veux défendre avant
tout la vérité éternelle et fait 10 des
emails inconciliables
je ne veux pas que tout parent mais oui
mais quinze jours ce ne sera pas non
c'est rien 15 jours c'est rien tu
trouves chaque mais tu mets mon cas je
t'aime je n'aime que toi
alors ne part pas barre car il est
nécessaire que lucie profitent de ces
quinze jours pour s'offrir un avenant à
passer votre fidélité et extrêmement
dangereuse car elle vous donne à tous
les deux le goût de la propriété et je
vous le prédis amènera des deux ans j'ai
cet avis en théorie comme en théorie les
moyens de dénicher le bonheur sont
souvent si inattendue alors pour te
rendre heureux c'est d'apprendre et
croyez moi ne vivait pas avec ses
valeurs dangereuse
voyez c'est banqueroute qui éclate tous
les jours suicide divorce un meurtre
passionnel
allez-vous vous aussi précipité vos
désirs et vos sentiments
dans un pareil coupe gorge mais il est
libre et la selva par fille à quelle
heure à 3h05 tout à l'heure non mais oui
je suis au pied
je préparais les taux sont bas
elle est très forte comment ça parce que
naturellement tu sais que depuis trois
semaines elle a un amant ses caisses que
qu'est ce que tu dis comment tu
l'ignoraient par donc alors là j'ai
gaffé même que suite à l'uci en avant
qu'est ce que tu dis du 6 août il tua un
amant mois depuis trois semaines
moi c'était une blague
pour voir la gueule que tu ferais et à
quel point le temps libre elle aussi les
mêmes monstres hume et remarques comme à
plaisanterie et mon expérience marché
tout aussi bien avec elle
comment as tu pu croire qu'une chose
pareille remarque il est libre elle est
libre enfin qu'il disant ma parole
parler de la liberté à des amoureux
c'est par les grecs un chinois
jacques tu ne dois pas douter de moi
mais que le tue si un jour non si ce
malheur arrive que j'aime un autre homme
aussitôt que moi même je le saurais je
te le dirai au grand dam féminines comme
ce gentil alors si vous le prévenez
c'est que vous serez certain de le
prendre ce faux la mort autrement ce
serait auprès de jacques un chantage
ignoble donc donc voulu dire et sans
qu'il puisse rien qu'entre votre
décision
don cherry ce soir je vais coucher dans
le lit d'un autre monsieur
que tu connais peut-être mais comme je
suis une femme honnête je te préviens et
là-dessus tâche de bien dormir
charmante ni des amis jacques sont
odieux
je ne veux plus qu'il recommence et je
recommencerai car je vais vous mettre en
garde
pour des gens comme vous l'amour est la
porte d'entrée de la famille ta gueule
ta gueule attention ça commence à sentir
chez vous la lavande et la pile de draps
et puis le bonheur mais en cours comme
des confitures qu'est ce que c'est
qu'est ce que c'est bon c'est bien moi
oui quelqu'un m'a dit comme ça à mettre
ma propre
hop
attends tu vas te dire mes amis laissez
moi seul volet vous j'ai quelqu'un
recevant qui est cette personne de
monter allé dans la chambre avec lui si
je tiens absolument à se promener seul
tant que je n'irai pas vous cherchez et
surtout tâche d'empêcher chers amis
d'écouté à la porte je t'expliquerai
nous pouvons sortir dignement situe
préférant il n'y a qu'un escalier dans
la maison allé dans la chambre avec lui
si je préfère gm dessus tout elle
bonjour jacques jean paul
je te remercie de m'avoir reçu bien que
je ne t'ai pas écrit d'avancé
si toi je craignais que tu ne répondent
pas à la coupe du monde entend rendez
vous tandis que je me doutais bien que
tu me dirait d'entrée quand tu me sors
est derrière la porte et jette aurait
reçu de toute façon fun car j'imagine
bien que si tu viens ce n'est pas sans
motif et si je venais sans motif je
viens tu fais ici de voir et puis savoir
ce que tu deviens s'est tu n'as rien
d'autre à mener non maman n'est pas
malade ni très beaux ni très heureuse
mais n'est pas souffrante elle avait eu
ces jours ci à j'habite maintenant avec
un moment et tente adrienne là bas chez
nous
juniors sans doute que j'ai renoncé à la
vie de paris ah non dans les deux
lettres que maman va envoyer elle ne me
parlait pas de toi c'est justement pour
éclaircir la situation
non je je t'écoute eh bien voilà tu
m'écoutes je te parle
nous sommes près calme l'un et l'autre
je suis là n'est ce pas déjà un très
grand progrès progrès vers quoi faire
une réconciliation que j'estime utile
quand ça ne serait que pour le bonheur
de non non je ne sais pas très bien ce
qu'il faudrait dire main ce n'est pas
faute d'avoir préparé des discours
depuis le fameux jour je n'ai guère
cessé de te parler dans ma solitude avec
ces mamans qui t'a suppliait de venir
non non il va sans dire que moment
serait très heureuse de notre
réconciliation et ça n'est pas
impossible n'est ce pas ça le tout de
même deux frères et tente adriers elle
est dans un état un curieux
ta fuite avec mademoiselle blondel l'a
tellement estomaqué qu'elle ne juge pas
ton acte lui semble en dehors des
mesures normal une chose qui dépasse
l'entendement humain
hier soir à table j'ai prévenu moment et
tente adrienne de la démarche que je
venais de décider j'ai dit que j'irai
offrir une réconciliation et que même je
ne ferai rien au contraire pour éviter
mademoiselle blondel g a ajouté que je
te demanderai je n'en parlerai tout à
l'heure de ces choses tu es seul ici ram
je sais que tu habites avec mademoiselle
blondel mais en ce moment tu es seul je
suis des amis étaient là mais ils
viennent de partir tu me permets de te
poser une question
puis heureux
oui
et 1
elle aussi je crois
comme je suis calme
je suis même très heureux de votre bon
noël à le jour enfin le de ton départ
j'ai d'abord cru à une blague
tu te souviens comme les boules en bois
et ton système solaire que j'ai retrouvé
dans toutes les pièces de la maison
tu vas encore te poser une question
jacques tu n'avais jamais vu ma
demoiselle blonde n'est ce pas avant ce
jour là n'ont jamais tu me le jure je te
le jure et vous êtes parti comme ça tout
de suite
oui c'est insensé
je te demande pardon je te pose beaucoup
de questions mais il faut me comprendre
donc je fais ici à paris moi je suis
seule imagination marche les questions
et les questions je vis parmi les
questions comme un bateau sur les vagues
on m'a dit qu'à paris meunier une vie à
ces artistes se fait ce mouvement
d'habiter paris avant oui mais est une
vie modeste elle pas dit il nous avons
décidé de parler le moins possible du
passé
je n'ai plus de voiture non mon auto et
joseph le chauffeur appartenaient à la
task compagnie je les ai dû les rendre
quand j'ai démissionné
c'était une voiture prêtée au chef du
personnel américains ont une manière de
concevoir les choses maintenant je
m'absente dans la campagne
tu enfin vous parlé quelques fois de de
chez nous de la maison oui
rarement
tu ne t'es jamais posé cette question
quelles peuvent être les sentiments de
paul mon égard et et à l'égard de
mademoiselle blondel d'ailleurs si tu as
essayé de deviner situe à imaginer
toutes les solutions possibles toutes
les solutions sont bonnes
toutes sans exception je suis passé par
tous les sentiments j'ai été victime des
idées les plus différentes
en vérité je n'en pense plus rien
maintenant que je suis près de toi c'est
comme une délivrance
depuis six mois je n'ai jamais si bien
respirer maintenant de lui on ne choisit
pas sa vie c'est comme mon kart wii
parce que je joue aux cartes
forcément on n'est pas à la campagne tu
comprends et bien aux cartes on a
quelquefois maldonne et c'est toujours
quand on a le plus beau jeu mais à quoi
bon s'entêter dans sa colère j'entends
dire en temps j'ai fini par comprendre
que tu avais le droit pelé mais non je
crie je n'ai jamais tant parlé depuis
six mois je suis je suis très ému et je
voudrais te poser encore une question
qui va te surprendre peut-être dix mois
chaque dix mois avais je raison de
vouloir épouser mademoiselle blondel
enfin n'est-elle pas une jeune fille que
l'on peut présenter à sa famille en
dépit des apparences de votre départ
c'était bien une femme n'est ce pas dont
on pouvait être le mari je ne comprends
tu imagines sans difficulté ce que tente
adrienne a pu dire de mademoiselle
blondel sans difficulté et tente
adrienne se trompent
naturellement tu vois ce que je veux
dire tu comprends bien le sens on ses
mots dans ma bouche tu te moques pas moi
en l'air et ainsi vous vous êtes aimée
tout de suite pourquoi te faire souffrir
peut au moins lui dis bien d'autres la
souffrance ne s'embarrasse pas de
politesse
depuis six mois je vis dans votre
intimité quand on a été dans l'état où
j'étais car maintenant c'est fini je
suis guéri
si tu savais comme on s'habitue certains
sentiments et à certaines visions et au
début dames c'est simple tu vas me
comprendre je ne crois plus à l'enfer
qu'entend on en sort toujours
enfin
on s'y habitue
elle va rentrer non j'ai rendez vous
enfin nous devons nous retrouver dans un
restaurant du vieux nous nous marchons
ensemble 1
enfin je te suis très bien entendu
devant la porte
oui non c'est j'ai un article à écrire
je suis journaliste maintenant je sais
je sais eh bien je vais te laisser
écrire ton article lire jacques c'était
un nom bien sûr ne le frapperait pas
excusez moi
les messieurs c'est pour donner des gaz
de gaz puis 72 prend 15 centimes
oui il ya deux mois vous comprenez alors
écoutez vous allez être jantes et de
repasser l'impossible monsieur c'est la
troisième fois que je présente je n'ai
pas de mener sur moi et je suis tout
seul ici tout seul bon alors la
conscience je sais pas ce qu'elle dit
puisqu'elle m'a dit vous pouvez monter
les cinq étages la petite dame est chez
elle je vous dis que non elle retient
jeu m'a dit oui
elle n'a pas raison de mentir alors que
tel que je crois votre métier d'amal et
là j'ai pu me rendre à ce soir voilà 100
francs oui je te remercie régalez vous
orge pas se payer aujourd'hui
oui il faut le conseil qui ne peut
comprendre car demain il faudra passer à
la caisse à partir de 4 ans
mademoiselle blondel et ici je te dis
que non cette porte donne sur votre
chambre sans doute oui
tu ne veux vraiment pas que je te prête
un peu d'argent on n'hésite pas je n'ai
plus besoin d'argent mois maintenant
non je te remercie tu sais les partis
faire le marché avec qu'est ce qu'il y
avait dans mon portefeuille sans
réfléchir évidemment qu'à un encaisseur
se répandent ans tu comprends mais elle
fait au marché de près par ton déjeuner
et vous êtes là tous les deux elle te
sert à table
je sais qu'elle est là jacques derrière
cette porte ne réponds pas je le sais
écoute je vais te demander une seule
chose n'as tu pas pour me la montrer une
photographie d'elle oui je vais
t'expliquer figure-toi d'un fou en
premier un moment de fureur j'ai tout
déchirer détruit brûlé
maintenant je la reconnaîtrai bien sûr
si elle entrait mais je ne vois plus
très bien figurer d'autres brouillent et
dans ma tête et ça j'aurais aimé de la
revoir en photo non je n'en ai pas et
bien
un autre jour je pense ça n'était qu'une
curiosité de gosse en fait j'aurais aimé
l'avoir écoute je suis descendu dans un
hôtel au dessus de la régence qui mon
ancien café veux tu que nous nous
rencontrions demain tous les deux toi et
moi
mais oui ah non non non de dieu demain
je pars pour la pologne pour la pologne
avec avec mademoiselle blondel nom seul
à reportage juste une quinzaine ouais tu
vas lui c'est mademoiselle blondel
quinze jours seuls à paris avant elle
vivait bien seul à paris oui mais
j'étais là toujours moi et elle avait
son travail et c'était une jeune fille
écoute - jacques
j'ai besoin de savoir répond moi elle ne
me trompais pas n'est ce pas c'était
bien une jeune fille honnête avec
laquelle on pouvait faire de sa vie mais
oui alors
et voilà la raison de ma visite oui je
le dis plutôt que je ne le pensais mais
ça vaut mieux pourquoi ne les pousse du
port
mais je l'épouserais bien moi là et elle
se maria jeune arrangerait t-il pas tous
mariés vous pourriez revenir à la maison
voir moment moi même à la maison étant
son beau frère je pourrais l'avoir car
je t'autorise veut dire que dès à
présent je la reverrai sans rancune mais
pour cela jacques enfin tu ne va tout de
même pas la laisser maintenant aller
d'aventuré en aventure
jacques tu aimes mademoiselle blondel
oui alors épouse là or ce n'est pas un
ordre tu penses bien mais je me suis
fait à votre amour et je vous aimerai
tous les deux comme un frère et nous
reprendrons une vie normale heureuse
écoute écoute je dîne à la régence
si tu as quelque chose à me dire ce soir
j'attendrai un peu en fumant des pipes
et en lisant le journal un je me
mettrais face à la porte et je
t'attendrai tard si tu ne viens pas je
repartirai demain chez nous où tu
m'écrire à la date de son retour n'est
ce pas oui je te le promets à ces quinze
jours on me semblait plus long que ces
derniers six mois maintenant que nous
sommes décidés je suis impatient que
tout rentre dans l'ordre
il ya beaucoup changé je redoutais un
peu cette première visite
je savais bien que tout s'arrangerait à
la longue mais la première fois je ne
croyais pas que tu serais ici un jour
toi est venu le premier à la régence ce
soir un coup d'état les travaux 15 jours
et tu sais je ne vous en veux plus ni à
l'un ni à l'autre vous vous aimez pour
la vie ils vont bien et que je m'incline
méritoire prend garde
si si elle se laissait aller un jour à
je ne sais quelle folie qui vous sépare
si elle ne se sentait pas sûr de toi
avec un jour elle parle tu ne penses pas
à toi qu'un jour tu le pourrait ne plus
la voir parce qu'elle serait partie
regarde moi je vieillis 1
aussi je sais bien
trois mois soit le plus fort mon petit
gars d'la fait tout ce que tu peux faire
pour la garder et crois moi à ce soir
[Applaudissements]
revenir à mon p'tit jacques parent
tranquille pour la pologne
j'ai décidé l'uci à te tromper pendant
son absence ah oui à ton retour sur le
quai de la gare
c'est une vue six nouvelles mois la pmm
fous moi le corps ah bon alors triste à
un mauvaise nouvelle mais les mauvaises
nouvelles n'existe pas les nouvelles
sont ceux que nous les faisons ah bon
alors néanmoins comme je te vois encore
plus nerveux qu'un sergent de ville
chers amis te salue et vous salue je te
dirais tu as des amis secret non mon
vieux mais je voudrais rester seul avec
le si j'en ai encore le droit oui bon
bon bon ben je pars tu n'as plus besoin
de moi là et bien ce soir lors comme
d'habitude à la vérité fait ça comme
d'habitude dans ce soir là non au train
a oui c'est vrai
à ce soir jacques max
tout à l'heure je vais te dire pourquoi
tant de précautions
mais comme tu es nerveuse te voici pas
si des faits tu n'as pas dit la vérité
tout à l'heure quelle vérité voyage en
pologne c'est un prétexte qu'elle
pourrait même quitter au nom alors cette
famille ici crois tu que je ne tolèrerai
qu'une femme 26 pourquoi chez nous une
autre femme tu sais bien que tu es libre
tu recevras ici ton amant alors pourquoi
nous jouer cette comédie voyant dans
cette comédie de la femme forte de
l'homme sans préjugés en tout cas si je
joue une comédie c'est pour toi qu'a
signe avec moi je veux te dire ne me dit
pas toujours que veux tu dire mais si je
joue les femmes fortes c'est de jouer
les hommes avod mais si tu pas que cette
liberté dont tu parles je te la donne
pour que tu ne la prennent pas et c'est
ce que je peux te donner de plus rares
parce que je t aime par dessus tout
je l'aï aussi je vais te faire de la
peine on regarde mes yeux et je l'air
d'un homme qui ne t'aime plus alors
qu'elle peine que tu veux faire quand
nous sommes partis ensemble comme de
fous tu as compris non moi je croyais
savoir tuer tes jolies et si je trouvais
la blague un peu énorme elle avait
justement à côté définitif dont je me
réjouissais car elle me libérer à tout
jamais de ma famille nous étions jeunes
et nous avons été surpris n'est ce pas
nous avons été surpris nous mêmes par
notre fuite car rien ne fut prémédité
comme tu as peur des mots
j'ai souvent pensé que tu vivais avec
moi par défi contre ton frère tu croyais
et je te mets contre mon frère est une
ans souffrait pas tué mais comme tu
pouvais avec des bonnes odeurs et moi je
m'arrangeais avec la présence pour être
heureuse quand même voilà
eh bien je te demande pardon de te dire
ces mots après six mois mais aujourd'hui
je suis absolument certain de thé mais
ce n'est pas vrai je ne t'aime pas
contre mon frère je t'aime pour moi je
t'aime pour toi je t'aime j'avais
tellement peur que des scènes ou si par
aventure dit ces mots là l'amour du
s'est insinué peu à peu dans notre vie
dans le sentiment dans nos idées comme
le musée mûron sans savoir au nom je
savais moi c'est vrai depuis notre
première soirée au bord de l'eau dans la
nuit j'aimais déjà les yeux fermés
bouleverser ses surprises des mets un
homme que je ne connaissais pas aidé
mais pour la première fois crois tu
m'aimais assez pour mémé toujours
toujours pour moi et si l'on laisse ton
avenir tranquille je veux que tu me
réponds tu m'aimes tu je te dis qu'on ne
peut pas aimer un ordre plus que je ne
t'aime alors mais si je vais te dire une
chose grave j'ai peur des calembredaines
de tous ces idiots que je t'ai fait
connaître du si je t'aime et je veux qu
aucun autre homme ne te sert comme moi
dans ses bras lui si le serbe comme moi
dans ses bras lui si tu veux tu
m'épouser
veux tu que nous marions t'épouser tu
veux m'épouser
tu m'aimes assez pour ne plus penser aux
autres femmes tuent même assez pour
croire que tu ne me quittera jamais que
je serai ta femme jusqu'à la fin que
maintenant nos regards ne se détacheront
plus l'un de l'autre que toujours je te
sentirais près de moi qu'il y aura plus
jamais pour moi de mes envies dans
laquelle on votre seul le soir avec plus
lourd que la fatigue l'angoissent
d'attendre le lendemain j'avais peur
qu'un jour tu ne rentres pas et tu veux
m'épouser
[Rires]
bien sûr que nous n'arrivons pas mais
comme je t'aime de l'avoir désiré et
d'avoir que neuf escales maman que
toutes les autres femmes quand tu es
plus pour toi bien sûr que nous nous
marierons pas nous marierons non les
jours un peu la haine tennis en simple
et si tu ne sers pas comme je t'aime et
comme j'ai peur par si je suis jaloux
affreusement jaloux toi mais si si je
t'aime c'est pour la vie et pour moi
tout seul je suis ta femme mais oui j'ai
ramené à tanabe si les amoureux sont
fidèles comme les vivants respire et
lorsqu on s'aime comme le musée non le
mariage n'est pas un lien de plus c'est
un cadeau qu'on sorte c'est un
remerciement au bonheur c'est c'est la
manière qu'on a de dire aux autres tous
les deux nous aimons pour la vie et vous
tous qui vous croyez nos amis vous
n'êtes que les passants il me semble
déjà que nous avons toujours vécu à si
tu connait enfin que je sais maintenant
ton secret mais secret oui il se crée ta
vie tu mèneras toujours
pourquoi me regardes tu es si c'était
dans toi l'homme que j'attendais voilà
j'ai le sentiment de découvrir d'un seul
coup ma vigne
voilà je connais déjà ma vie j'étais
ressemblera oui
jacques depuis six mois nous avons été
heureux si heureux sans y penser
et maintenant il va falloir que tout le
reste de notre vie ressemble à ces six
mois bonheur et un bonheur enfin sur et
tu sais maintenant que tu peux compter
sur moi et moi je sais que tous les
autres hommes ne compteront plus pour
toi tu seras revenu sur la terre pour
m'aimer et pour n'aimait que moi jacques
pourquoi avoir mêlé aujourd'hui à notre
amour cette erreur de ne plus nous aimer
un jour mais justement je ne veux pas
que tu ne puisses plus mais un jour je
veux te garder pour te garder jeu fermé
toutes les portes
pourquoi n'avoir pas attendu que nous
soyons bien vieux toi et moi pour
découvrir que nous nous étions et mais
toute notre vie peut-être serais-tu
parties avant et j'ai besoin d'assurer
mon bonheur
jacques tu demande une femme en mariage
mais ce n'est pas une femme c'est toi
jacques est venu de voir c'est bien
c'est pas l'appeler final comprend ta
mère est venue n'est ce pas ma mère
pourquoi ma mère mais non âge il faut
qu'elle était vue de demander une
régularisation non ce n'est pas le maire
il ne s'agit pas de régularisation c'est
mon frère qui est venu
que tu venu faire avec quels reproches
imbéciles date il trouve léo caron
proches elle avait théorisé dire mais il
est venu très triste et très calme pour
me voir
c'était tout de même pas lui qui t'a
demandé de m'épouser
alors qu est il venu faire tu as porté
son verdict du jugement définitif sur ce
qu'il doit taper notre conduit non pas
du tout il est devenu très simple mais
pourquoi cette demande en mariage tout
de suite après la visite de ton frère
quel changement
ce n'est pas parce que tu veux dire
semble épouser non je n'ai pas changé
mais j'ai découvert que ajouté mais on a
propriétaire la propriétaire comme il
faut aimer à 2 pour toujours ou du moins
avec la conviction que ce sera pour
toujours ou en voiture avec la condition
de les perdre ce soir j'étais certaine
que je t'aurais aimé toucher au rêve de
petite fille donne moi la main pour
entrer dans la vraie la main dans la
main tu me disais qu'il n'y avait plus
d'ordre que tout était cassé à travers
le monde que nous vivions à la fin d'une
civilisation et oui il n'ya plus d'ordre
l as pu lire archi plus de ces bonnes la
de héros ou de saint auquel on se
raccroche
mais si les hommes ont fait tomber les
barrières avant d'en savoir élever
d'autres ils ont gardé leurs choeurs
d'hommes et rial existent pour moi dans
le monde aujourd'hui à mes yeux que ton
bonheur à toi et son malheur à lui
écoute toi tu te rappelles finaux ce
petit chien que nous avons eu deux mois
et bien j'aurais dû comprendre dès ce
moment-là qu'il n'y avait plus de vérité
dans son regard de bonne bête que dans
les pirouettes sans danger du cher ami
ce que je vais te dire et bien un
sentimental pleurnichard même mais il
faut une pensée bien forte et les
convictions solides pour rester
insensible aux larmes d'un
mais que vient faire le chagrin de ton
frère entre nous regarde
mais j'ai compris le chagrin d'un homme
qui ne savait plus je regardais mon
frère et je me voyais mois sans toi
alors je vais me garder pour toujours je
m'en a rien qu'à moi tu comprends oui
les autres femmes ses fils je vais te
détruire pour te garder je prends ton
bras et en avant marche pour un désert
sans homme ni femme ou seul brûlera
notre amour crois tu que nous ne nous
aimions pas assez quand nous nous
aimions sans le savoir parmi tous ces
dangers
mais justement je ne veux plus de danger
tu ne crois pas que le danger est aussi
attirant et remuant de nos jours que le
diable d'autres fois non toute notre vie
va se transformer d'abord les petits
copains à l'accord chers amis à l'apport
leur histoire à la porte
ensuite c'est le journal vainement de
trop de temps je démissionne démissionne
je cherche autre chose et puis en
attendant je demanderai à la maison les
revenus qu'ils me doivent
qu'ils demanderaient de l'argent chez
toi et naturellement c'est l'héritage de
mon père il va leur demander à sou parce
que j'étais brouillé avec eux mais
maintenant tout va s'arranger
paul m'assure que si nous nous marions
tous les deux nous serons très très bien
reçus à la maison à nous retournerions
là bas en passant mais que ça dit on
ferait exactement ce que je te dis
attention jacques tu veux être lent que
j'attendais il faut être aussi grand
qu'un rêve de petite fille s déchoir que
de mener sa femme chez sa mère si tu ne
sens pas que tu ne comprends pas ce que
je veux dire c'est que tu as déjà changé
jacques mais tu es folle d'abord je vais
téléphone au journal que je refuse
l'enquète en pologne des camarades sont
trop peureux de me remplacer
non non tu vas aller là bas mais
pourquoi tu étais la vraie de ce départ
quand je te les a lancés parce que je
craignais que jour devient avec toi le
dernier jour de notre amour maintenant
nous avons la vie devant nous et
d'ailleurs toit dans un an tu
regretteras ce maillage marteau et non
pas je veux je n'aurai pas de chagrin 15
jours puis toute notre vie nous n'avons
plus à être avare de nos jours il faut
que je reste tu sais que dans dans trois
semaines tu peux être mal amir mansi je
m'occupe de formalité
madame miremont madame miremont c'est à
partir en pole jack c'est impossible
montrant pendant moins d'une heure déjà
tu vois il le faut il voudrait pas être
et médine 500 courage c'est incroyable
tu veux vraiment que je pas vraiment
pourquoi ta valise que reporter tiens
toi chemise mais je ne sais pas je ferai
en route on va faire ta valise de
données toucher les choses qui sont
accompagnés
si j'avais su j'aurais demandé un
passeport pour toi c'est très bien mais
seulement au moment du coup de téléphone
au journal o comme c'est loin oui c'est
loin
j'en ai peur d'eux à ce moment là le
journal il en même temps je vais besoin
d'eux alors je n'ai pas ans et leur
parler de toi et pourquoi mais tu ce
cendrier entre mes chemises
tu te rappelles pas ces cendriers du
bonheur le premier cadeau que tu essaies
mais je pars pas pour une éternité
malades miremont dans 15 jours je serai
là si ton travail exige t'en supplie
reste un peu plus à moi si le faux qui a
confiance en moi je te jure d'être
fidèle jusqu'à ton retour jusqu'à
m'enfonce aux hommes a mûrement nous
n'avons qu'à peine je vous les donne
quinze jours où je vais t'aimer mon
jacques plus que je ne t'ai jamais mais
c'est encore assez long 15 jours quand
on est content davance un deux trois
quatre derniers jours de liberté mal à
tenir mon ouïe et à mon retour je te
prends mes braves et vrac pour se
refermer sur quoi ne se rouvriront pas
rater mon train
dépêche-toi le début ce toit
tu veux que je partais et tu pleures
mais pourquoi pleures tu comme ça je
t'aime plus que tout au monde
oui et il a plus que moi au monde comme
tu es courageuse encore plus que tu ne
crois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout le monde te conseillerais de
prendre ce bouillon goûte le seulement
gelé confectionner moi même j'aime
l'odeur me suffit il est excellent ce
bouillon qui peut l'emporter pour
comment tu ne veux même pas écouté les
buts de diges dante adrian refuse
toujours de s'alimenter
je suis morte que vous ne vous occupiez
plus de moi continuez vos folies lester
mort pour toi tu as voyages j'ai besoin
de votre signature pour la nouvelle
vente du bois d'amour
comment le notaire n'a pas encore ouvert
mon testament
j'ai pourtant inscrit la veille de ma
mort il ouvre qu'il exécute une fois
pourquoi cet entêtement adriean vêtu jeu
consenti savoir ce nigaud aller prier le
posa de revenir ici avec sap donzelle 8
paul pardonner alors que deux pertes de
calatrava étaient toutes en plus nous
allons rater une affaire splendide mais
pâte molle
crois tu donc la farce n'apparaissent
août durée avec le bois d'amour ma vie
je suis restée une demoiselle parce que
je possédais avec mon frère le bois
d'amour
ils ont construit parmi nos sapins dans
des hôtels de luxe ou les marquises une
danse et en robe de perles mais moi dans
le bois d'amour me suis seulement pourra
mais je mords que vieille fille en fait
marqué juste trouver le moyen de nous
présenter une vision ses cocottes 10ème
look et toi vous est morte tenta de rio
né vous marchez
les morts ne marche pas a lancé tu mon
garçon ya des marques qui ne s'en
vantent pas ok reviennent suis une
revenante voit bien que j'ai droit de
marcher
n'oublie pas que je suis morte à cause
de toi d'abord que c'est eu des morts
pour en parler des vivants las signer le
contrat de vente ne tue pas de la terre
j'ai d'abord voulu faire l'avocat à
paris puis je ne sais quels autres
sottises et maintenant tu reviens à la
terre va se promener monde veut la terre
aussi ce moratoire pour loi de rügen
france ou bouillon est il si difficile
de comprendre que je ne vis plus avec
vous je suis d'un autre monde
laissez moi vous dire maintenant que
d'avoir eu tout juste pour mission dans
la vie ou de posséder le bois d'amour ne
vous a peut-être pas donner un champ
d'expérience suffisants pour juger evans
et ma vie nigaud attend d'être morte
aussi attaquent nos questions en bagarre
des nouvelles tenues pour raisonnable de
reagan et ses cuvées
si vous étiez moins fou vous me laisser
mourir
ça m'avait fait moi même dit qu il ne
s'est donc pas encore tous je vous
laisse
elle dit pas trop de mal des morts mais
quand même
et bien tout vider vos coeurs il vous
savoir soit du paradis
elle continue ont bien mauvais temps
quelle semaine
on ne peut pas dire que ce soit les
peuples les feuilles qui tombent c'est
le vent et la pluie tous les arrachent
elle est têtue comme votre père mais ça
dans votre terre était têtu pour des
idées saines et qui jamais je voulais tu
savoir eux
je ne sais plus rien mais naturellement
vous parlait toujours de croire et on
pas qu'elle cherche
non mais c'est vrai ça elle voudrait
vous brouillez quand ça ne pas manger
comme celle durera pas longtemps
tranquille histoire d'amour elle mange
plus que toi seulement elles se cachent
les morts ne font pas les choses comme
tout le monde
elle boit de l'eau la nuit et puis sur
val it et confitures les peaux doivent
disparaître mais aussi en rade avec le
bois de moore
c'est scandaleux casser ainsi les ailes
à la plage elle destine est ratée pour
le pays et les grands sportifs comment
cet avenir c'est 20% plus joli que la
boule 50% moins vulgaire que biarritz
vous êtes ses héritiers vous trouverez
la propriété plus tard ah oui votre
grand père avait acheté ces terres là
trois centimes le mètre
allez croyez moi mes enfants il faut
savoir attendre
et oui alors jacques tu es de vie de ne
rien brusquer
où que se tourne à 10 pôles de fond de
vie d'ailleurs c'est peut-être une
excellente chose qu'elle refuse de vous
c'est dès aujourd'hui
sait-on jamais comment tourner les
aventures c'est vrai on s'attend au pire
et puis aussi que tout est remis en
place au nom d'ailleurs je ne dis pas ça
pour nom naturellement je ne craignais
pas que moi tout de même je suis bien
heureuse mes enfants sans cette stupide
folie de votre tante
on croirait qu'elle provoque oui
je vais m'occuper du dîner tu viens avec
moi paul non je reste ici pas dire un
peu alors viens jacou éplucher les
légumes avec marie alors maman va
tranquillement est accusé mais je suis
tranquille mes enfants je vous aime tous
les deux
et depuis six mois vous vous entendez si
bien ah oui oui ce serait dommage
mais quelle dans wii
j'ai vu le journal non quoi les autres
de marque à la plage du bois d'amour
on annonce l'arrivée au mercedes de
mademoiselle lucie blondel à la
dessinatrice la plus en vue du plus
côtés de nos couturiers parisiens
elle est arrivée de biarritz en avion en
compagnie de sa secrétaire
marzak il ne s'agit pas d'un avion de
ligne mais de l'avion privé du président
de la filiale européenne de l'aisne du
michigan a à avion que pilote est elle
même
mademoiselle lucie blondel plus sportive
que jamais
parfait
j'ai déjà été en l'avion toi non ils toi
moi non plus
c'est ridicule argent nous tous même
pour un jeu recevoir le baptême de l'air
oui bien sûr qu'à baptême n'engage
jamais rien il faut suivre la mode faire
comme tout le monde
comme tout le monde rue tandis que les
femmes pilotes que sont tout de même
massira sa mademoiselle lucie blondel
est une fin au non non non entre nous je
t'en prie appel à lui si tout simplement
lucie l'habitude de ce petit nom ou et
savoir comment il se prononce sur tous
les tons musset du si c'est presque de
notes de musique
lucie la seule du sila seule lucie
l'unique et je deviens politique
et voilà sa photographie je ne leur est
pas reconnue en d'un manteau de sport le
cliché est raté d'ailleurs
ça me revient à ce que je venais te
demander tout le temps si on allait
chasser demain mais le père le bourg
nous invite à faire l'ouverture avec lui
et tu veux la chasse bon j'ai envie
d'essayer
on dit que déjà fameux fusil toi on se
lasse de tout c'est la vie c'est la
mission bull jetteront chasser l'hiver
dernier en ne pensant qu'à bah oui tu
sais à quoi laurent ruquier foutu le
camp tous les deux alors j'ai chassé
chasser et depuis je n'aime plus
beaucoup les fusils ni les brumes du
matin et dieu sait si j'ai chassé tous
les matins pour ne pas rester dans un
lit où je ne dormais pas et en fait
chasse je chassais devant moi des bêtes
que je manquais et alors que les idées
que je voulais chassé pour mon dieu ne
suivait mieux que mon chien
jacques s'est tu un jour le dernier jour
j'ai chassé que j'ai tué mon chien en le
visant pour le supprimer
parce que chaque fois qu'il revenait
vers moi chaque fois que je le revoyais
à chaque fois qu'il japet je pensais pas
ce que je voulais oublier
qui comprend les associations d'idées
marchait à plein rendement enfin le
chien fidèle et la fidélité
le chien le dernier a mis des malheureux
le chien à cette bête qu'on ne peut pas
perdre comme ses souvenirs
parvenez pas égaré à perdre dans mon
passé je me disais si mon chien le père
je ne penserai plus elle est le chien
refait alors je les cuis d'étudiants
j'ignorais des démêlés avec la chasse je
te demande pardon
non pourquoi boum c'est à moi de te
demander pardon d'avoir attendu dans
notre famille une femme pareille capable
de nous rien paul tu veux bien les
parents d'autres choses pourquoi nous
pouvons très bien parlé bien au
contraire ces conversations me repose
elle m'agace bons joueurs là on est bon
très bien les tenu le choc et j'en suis
contenu toi tu ne veux pas convenir que
c'est une garce tu prétends pas que tu
attendais cette fin d'aventuré
prétoriens tu te savais que l'attention
de pologne la maison sera vide non tu
pars seulement 15 jours pour la pologne
et l'oiseau des niches et après elle est
partie a eu partie aisée tout ce que je
veux on départage pire que puis-je andy
puisque je ne savais rien de ce départ
est une enseigne toujours variable
et pourtant depuis six mois à tulle à
rumine sa fuite
chacun son tour pense à ta maison vide
le jour de ton retour sans un mot
d'explication
oui c'est son genre pourtant notre
situation à tous les deux est assez
différente
toi tu as eu temps si j'ose dire de te
rassasié de carte qui me l'a bien chiper
un à un avant qu'elle ne décide de
plaquer définitivement l'émir monde en
somme toi qui l'a connu femme facile moi
sommes leur ai connu jeune fille car il
m'a joué et avec quel talent les vierges
farouche pendant des mois
paul je t'en prie de toi tu as beaucoup
menti à toi il est bien difficile
d'évaluer les mensonges des autres que
veux-tu la vie tourbillonne les paroles
restent sur place et
il est tellement simple d'accuser les
autres de mensonges
je comprends est ce un mensonge au fond
qu une saute d'humeur sont tout humain
qu'une soi-disant jeune fille foutent le
camp le soir de ses fiançailles avec le
frère du fiancé sautes d'humeur elle pas
vraiment pologne pour pendant ces quinze
jours d'absence préparer le déménagement
et la déménager elle à rester jusqu'au
dernier moment chez nous si elle savait
lentement d'arrivée j'avais télégraphié
et la table était mise pour vieux oui y
avait des gars ton frais dans une
assiette
ce que j'aimais d'une pâtisserie de
montparnasse et des fleurs sur la nappe
seulement avec un couvert et après avoir
attendu longtemps j'ai compris que ceux
couverts unique c'était le mien oui mais
elle n'est pas menteuse je devais
l'appeler par un mot tu vois je ne
dirais pas la menteuse pas quels mots
dirais tu je ne sais pas elle ne tablait
pourtant pas dit qu'elle était
dessinatrice de mode elle ne l'était pas
à l'oreille tu crois qu'elle a inventé
ça comme ça tout à coup avec gmail
relations et oui mon mieux c'est sa vie
qui continue tandis que la nôtre se
ralentit et s'arrête
balivernes le suma kenya où il prend pas
honteuse malheur de ma vie moi avons
tout simplement des parts qu'elle
voulait se marier avec moi aux plants et
fleurs d'oranger répond c'est pas un
mariage est un sacrilège de la jugent
très mal aux hommes ont effectivement je
n'ai guère de tendresse
je veux dire que tu la juge a coté un
cours des événements fous moi aussi je
veux la réussite escomptée de ma vie
allez ne parle aucune sam on a nous
sommes deux vieilles break n'y pensons
plus tu as pris ton numéro d'ordre parmi
les nombreux
amant de cette demoiselle va très bien
qu'elle doit avoir d'ailleurs depuis sa
première communion tu as profité de
l'aubaine parfait et j'ai couché avec
elle à moins d'importance que je ne les
pensais à certaines heures de ma vie
bonne idée nous irons chercher demain
nous partirons à l'aube en fumant une
bonne pub et puis nous organisons notre
vie ici bas tu tiens moi je propose de
construire une maison à une grande
maison avec deux ailes nous habiterons
chacun au trail et on serait sur une
terrasse et on verrait l'océan de la
terrasse et les gens diraient le château
des frères virmont un lait étaient
frères mourir mon papa avec une pole
pour y installer un beau télescope pour
toi c'est tu sais tu que j'ai souvent
pensé à des étoiles c'est vrai c'est
vrai que l'idée de ce grand vide console
wii peut-être pas tellement le vide mais
l'idée qu' on sera peut-être eu ailleurs
dans une de ces lumières et puis nous
font de la politique
un athée à tous un réactionnaire et moi
on de gauche pour nous changer
et bah tu vois nous serons arrivés à
nous entendre sur les points essentiels
et les choses sérieuses paraît petit
frère avant qu'ils ne passent des
siècles et ne nous marierons avec deux
défis et vous leur ont échappé belle
oui
mais pourquoi dix études je le juge est
à côté parce que le service
c'est peut-être l'ambition ambitieux
peut-être au je dis ça comme ça même je
dis ça sans savoir en fait je ne crois
pas non refoulement toute ambition
je peux voir très bien ce qu'elle
gagnait si je peux avec en plus des
violences à voir ce qu'elle pouvait
gagner de platine alors ça évidemment
elle ne gagne rien à s'enfuir avec moi
et puis parlons d'autre chose battu tous
mais bon film débute et encore moi je
pourrais croire qu'elle n'est pas
menteuse mais toi toi tu as eu la preuve
de sa fonderie
quelle preuve le jour de son départ avec
elle elle n'était pas elle n'était déjà
plus une vraie jeune fille comme le me
laisser croire une vraie jeune fille
mais pour moi ça non a naturellement est
un mensonge de cette gravité et bien que
refuse la victime notamment ouvert les
yeux
je dis non je voulais dire non je ne te
répondrai pas alors ce serait oui
jacques ce serait oui tu serais parti
avec ma fiancée et c'est toi qui le
premier l'a je crois pas que je ne
répondrai pas ne dit ni oui ni non
mini oui nous as oui je compense ces
noms mais elle t'a dit oui
et si gm daewoo en garde jacques à quoi
tu es 3 pas juste à la fin elle est
partie c'est entendu mais tu ne sais pas
comment mais comment est elle partie
jouant au foot je lui parle annonce que
je veux savoir ce que commenter les
parties de la première fois avec toi une
lettre que j'ai trouvé sur mon bureau
après au balang pardonne-moi jacques je
t'aime et je parle mais je te dis de me
répondre je veux savoir
mes deux premiers ennuis avec quel camp
vous êtes sauvés comme des voleurs tous
les deux ans jacques jacques si par
malheur péter son premier amour et que
ce soit toi qui ce soir là pendant que
je travaille de fureur dans ce coin
comme une bête que ce soit toi qui nous
avions décidé d'oublier cette femme
paule si tu m'as pris celle que
j'attendais depuis des mois celle qui se
refusait pas moi depuis des mois sans si
cette nuit-là centre ajoute c'était le
premier à la tenir
nous ne venons pas encore compris
comment un homme comme moi on était
arrivé à épouser sa dactylo et lucie
blondel la dessinatrice à plus en vogue
de paris et qui fait de l'avion
maintenant ils étaient tout simplement
ma dactylographe la dactylo voilà voilà
sa première apparition à charmante
souriante spirituel sautillante
dactylographe epal quand j'ai dû me voir
à paris tu m'a bien conseillé d'épouser
l'uci mais maintenant je croyais
quelques mains pour la vie il fallait
bien que je me résigne ne m'aimait pas
moi c'est un grand malheur voilà et
depuis que je suis revenu que croyait
tudor enfin comme il se doit d'être
plaqué ainsi je pensais que c'était une
grue
alors que tu es où nous coucher avec
elle toi ou un autre que ma portée mais
si vraiment si vraiment elle était aussi
en est qu elle le prétendait que par un
sortilège scandale tue mes valises nuit
tu peux pas savoir jacques ce que sept
gars m'a fait souffrir y avait moi et
moi j'attendais contre la porte de sa
chambre qu'elle me ferme étonné parce
que c'était une jeune fille elle disait
devenir une femme
dans cet hôtel de montagne ayant fermé
pendant trois jours mois le président de
la grosse compagnie est elle la petite
dactylo mais j'ai connu la toujours de
démence est absolument certain de
devenir la sont à mort et bien non tous
les soirs je l'embrassais les mains je
le suppliais genou
dans les couloirs de l'hôtel je me
relevais surpris par des clients je
tombé à genoux tout en larmes
la nuit je ne dormais pas ce que
j'attendais avec une patience vialan
parce que j'étais absolument syrte est
qu'un jour elle se donnerait celui à
faire le mariage pour être le premier
homme de son corps je leur ai promis de
tuer mandement je leur ai promis de tuer
notre meilleure plante ou être le
premier homme à la tenir serrer dans ses
bras nus et c'est à ce moment que je
vais arriver ici tout le temps c'est à
ce moment de ma vie que je les a menés
là et que toi tais toi j tant que d'être
mon avenir buts contre ces nuits 2 n'est
pas publié
palm aussi je souffre et c'est comme moi
de te libérer de toutes ces
complications sentimentale la souffrance
n'est pas un sentimental
elle est d'une extraordinaire précision
visite au congrès d'une extraordinaire
précision je vois des paysages de chair
et toi paul tout ça est chimérique
voyons tu souffres comme moi parce
qu'elle est partie tout simplement un
pro du tout bonjour mon foot est nulle
part le lendemain
mais pendant le lendemain matin
seulement tu me la voler une nuit trop
tôt
tu crois ça tu prends à ça mais si elle
était partie plus tard peut-être
souffrir et tuent davantage je m'en fout
de ta souffrance
j'entends mais je veux savoir et je vais
savoir aux mercedes
enfin si je lui parlerai j'attendrai
gela guetterait je la suivrai mais je
lui parlerai faudra bien qu'elle parle
l'avait vidéo
oxis douceur de mon père que vous êtes
je vais vous flanquer une tripotée
suffisante pour vous convaincre que si
vous êtes mort vous êtes d'une morte
sans fil mottaki acquis palm vient de
courir dehors pour avoir cette charmante
demoiselle blonde elle ajouté en folie
partie mais oui tel salaire ya maman il
rentrera sûrement avant dîner d'ailleurs
je vais le chercher je cours le chercher
geof pole mais qui met fussent ils
n'iront pas loin vous retrouver cette
charmante demoiselle blondel et
reviendront avec l coup j'ai invité
cette jeune personne à venir nous
visiter de toute urgence use du feu ne
t'inquiète pas des grands ados ont
besoin de se frotter à la petite lucie
de temps à autre pour bien s'entendre
d'abord elle ne viendra pas peut-être
pourtant après ce que j'ai fait j'en
serais étonné que tu fais mon dieu
douche pas tout à dieu
voila voila j'ai toujours vécu en
attendant et tout est passé rien n'est
arrivé que du malheur alors je reste
seule avec toi qui es méchante avec mes
deux grands fils sont les propres à rien
pourquoi d'abord le notaire est ce n'est
pas vraiment testament j'en avais donné
l'ordre
c'est pourquoi je suis morte je voulais
que tu saches tout de suite que paul est
déshérité comment tu as aussi des airs
ajouté paul louis paul et jacques tu as
déshérités mes fils oui mais tous mes
biens et ses données et c'est toi qui
m'as demoiselle lucie blondel
finalement tu état des lieux redonner un
jour tout mon argent j'ai préféré le lui
remettre moi même que tu me pardonnes ça
m'étonnerait dieu ne m'a jamais causer
du tracas
toute ma vie j'ai été démêlés avec lui
et j'ai pensé c'est de lui demander des
comptes
je n'ai jamais su être malheureuse as tu
connu mais malheur tu n'as jamais su
briller j'ai prié avec plus de ferveur
que toi mais j'ai eu dans un certain
silence quelques malheurs moi aussi
comment crois tu donc j'ai vécu moi qui
suis morte qui est fille tu n'as pas su
que j'ai été dupé par un homme à 20 ans
un homme que j'ai trois pas de mire et
un homme qui fait que je ne me suis pas
marié je pars de mon frère tu entends
ton mari oui tant mari je l'aimé d'amour
des mes 15 ans tout de suite sans savoir
mon frère l'a deviné
gt ça servant de 30 ans j'aurais
pardonner s'il avait épousé quelqu'un
que je puisse aussi admirer cas qu'il
épousait à toi sélectif
si dieu sur la terre punissez les
messieurs que tu es toujours bio c'est
toi qui voudraient me punir et qui
n'osent pas et quel pilote de ton espèce
refuse toujours de prendre à leur compte
sont à 10 ans noah qui a toujours fini
donc perdu l'habitude à face devant
désigner ces lust in tu ne vas pas
commencer à te désespéré à ton âge
oui jusqu'au nom dont il nous baptisé
kim a dupé et voilà mes deux grands fils
qui avait tout pour être heureux on a
toujours tout pour être heureux sauf le
bonheur si tu devais te vraiment
heureuse qui aurait pu thiennot adrienne
tu peut encore espérer toi tu as deux
grands fils que tu n'as pas rogner moi
je suis morte 1
et les morts sans avenir sont
terriblement thing mobile le passé est
un enfer dans les mains on n'a pas pu
sortir n'importe quoi tu es folle de
dieu oh mon dieu pourquoi ne l'avez vous
pas tenu plus serrée dans votre oeuvre
que peux-tu dont espérer avec des
lamentations comme s'il y avait quelque
chose à espérer ou est-elle notre
famille a perdu et puis y'a plus rien
maison
[Musique]
volonté soit fête oui oui oui c'est sa
volonté qui sera fait et pas la tienne
voilà mon dieu oh mon dieu je ne pouvais
pas croire que cette femme viennent ici
des prières ont toujours raté comme des
sauces mayonnaise
voilà comment le système revenir ici tu
si elle avait osé partir entre et ma
petite amie
comment osez vous revenir ici vous avez
eu raison de m'écrire même mais elle est
folle ne croyez pas et venez vous
asseoir ma petite brebis
célestine laisse nova prévenir jacques
tu ne veux jamais comment avez vous eu
revenir ici mais cette lettre me disais
allez vous en allez vous aurez tout le
mal que vous pouviez faire effet et
c'est un mal que ni vous ni personne ne
peut réparer et dieu lui-même s'il veut
qu'un jour mes deux fils soit ensemble
aux parades il devra d'abord vous en
chasser et vous chasser de leur mémoire
vous je les aimais comme un fils mais
tout espoir est il perdu pour jacques il
ne vous aime pas mais le médecin que dit
le médecin
le médecin mais quel médecin les
médecins sont des âmes venez jacques
vous demande
non je veux d'abord avant de le voir que
sa mère n'autorise à le voir et pour
l'amour du ciel dites moi ce que vous a
écrit on a écrit que jacques était
mourant et qu'il m'appelait or que dieu
te trame que dieu te tapes y en a pas
besoin de tes conseils pour savoir ce
qu'il a fait aux mondiaux mais fisc ont
surtout qu'il ne vous voit pas je vous
supplie de partir pendant que les
empêchent d'entrer bon tu vois si vous
seriez inventé cette lettre parce qu'il
y a des choses que j'ai besoin de savoir
beaucoup plus qu'on dit les morts
parlent tous vivent là j moi je ne suis
pas si gourmande je ne veux que prendre
votre cap un jour la mort vous enlèvera
tous vos vêtements
vous êtes un monstre de m'avoir dit que
jacques était dans un lit sans espoir
donc pas rêver dans cette voiture
blanche et rouge c'était bientôt et vous
venez ici qu'est ce que vous êtes venu
faire ici
je ne sais plus je veux savoir la vérité
oui oh oui
dites vous bien toutes vos petites
vérités car il n'y a pas de vérité
chacune de nos journées à sa propre
vérité nous en retournent dans un monde
contradictoires pourquoi suis-je ici
pourquoi suis-je ici je veux le savoir
notre attente avait décrit que vous
allez mourir avec vous m'appeliez folle
voici la lettre parce que j'allais
mourir et que je vous appelez vous
seriez revenus mais pourquoi êtes vous
parti c'est leur honneur qui vous a fait
revenir non junte et les jours je suis
parti j'ai eu trop de chagrin van der
maur trop de chagrin
j'ai parti en tenant les murs ne voyais
plus mon chemin je pleurais on me fait
des racontars sur moi non qui t'a fait
partie toi moi oui
comment vois tu n'as pas fini
devant toi je ne comprends plus et
pareil qui m'ont éloigné loin de toi tu
mens conduite loin dans une existence a
prévu devant toi n'explique rien et qui
ne comprendraient pas je ne comprendrais
pas moi même je ne comprends plus je
parle beaucoup devant toi pense ja nous
regardons pour la première fois depuis
le 23 mai oui notre chance de bonheur
est très compromise j'ai peut être
détourné notre destin tout échanger
entre nous alors ton visage mais elle a
changé du tout changé
sans doute mais tout de même ni toi ni
moi ni cette pièce est cette prison ni
notre passé au point que je ne puisse en
ce moment me raccroche et qu'elle seule
chose c'est vidic quoi je suis si
dépaysé devant toi que je me retrouve
que dans une chose c'est absolument
ridicule et tu vas rien pourtant si bête
à pleurer
je suis bouleversé tout simplement parce
que je reconnais de manière désastreuse
ta manière qui n'a pas changé de nous et
à cravate
si vous assez bête à pleurer pourquoi es
tu parti quand tu m'as laissé rentrer
seuls à paris tu mets mais je ne t'ai
jamais tentée mix jour là tu mens tu
n'as pas le droit de jacques dumas
cuisine d'un seul mensonge alors
pourquoi es tu parti parce qu'elle joue
serait venu où nous ne nous serions plus
aimée parce qu'un jour le malheur serait
venu c'est pourquoi je suis parti pour
ne pas gâcher le bonheur inespéré de ma
vie et la mort d'un seul homme
l'amour forcené d'un seul homme n'est-il
pas un mystère plus angoissant que tes
inquiétudes de femmes en liberté trop
pour liberté oui jacques c'est ainsi que
depuis six mois tu me parle sans arrêt
la nuit tu sais quand on se réveille
parce qu'on est trop fatigué suis encore
là à me parler ainsi aime dire des
choses atroces
moi aussi je suis habitué à devoir
toujours devant moi
toujours devant moi un seul jeu plus
fort dans mes bras
on pense que je vis ici dans un monde
absurde
non mais non je vis depuis six mois dans
un paradis dans un paradis aux au rabais
un paradis pour malheureux août est
toujours présente et les lointaines
moi aussi jacques j'ai pensé à toi tous
les jours toute la nuit j'étais près de
toi je réveille toi
c'est quand je me réveillais que le
cauchemar commence et jacques
avant dix mois quoi une chose que je
veux savoir
attention jacques quand sonne l'heure
des confidences et quelquefois plus
difficile d'écouter que tu parlais je
veux seulement savoir où tu étais parti
dans quel recul cachet quand je t'ai
cherché attendu pendant 11 jours
encore aujourd'hui je plains celui qui
comme moi c'est combien paris est grand
quand on soupçonne chaque fenêtre quand
on s'est dit pourquoi ne s'attelle pas
là mais non tandis que je m'interdis s'y
passe peut-être dans l'autre rue alors
on court tu comprends je voudrais servir
si tu es passé au coin de la rue de
seine et de vouloir saint-germain là je
suis resté deux jours et une nuit à
t'attendre sans quitter le défilé des
passants me répétant sans arrêt ne pas
bouger autant la callas leur être
obstiné attendre ma chance et tu passes
et là entre le deuxième et le quatrième
jour après mon retour
non répond pas si vite je t'en supplie
réfléchit après le deuxième et le
quatrième a été blessé à paris tu
n'étais plus à paris elle va ce n'est
pas juste non ce n'est pas juste tant
d'espoirs et les attend de chagrin s'il
y avait une justice dans le monde a
encore répondu au moins à une toute
petite chance de te rencontrer tu
n'étais plus à paris je désire savoir
que ma détresse provoquerait notre
rencontre n'était plus apparue si
j'avais été à paris j'aurais rodez
devant notre maison
pourquoi tu partout on est une mois
jacques tant pis cela durera ce que cela
durera nous partirons ensemble
oui aujourd'hui oui maintenant ce soir
oui ou ou tu voudras je sais que tu es
une femme célèbre chez les couturiers tu
ne regretteras pas cette vie brillante
comme tu voudras je ne peux t'offrir
qu'une existence mauvaise oui nous
l'aurons une petite maison et puis et
puis nous attendrons oui et puis la vie
continuera riz
ils disent que c'était au tel courage de
partir en sachant que tu ne remonterai
plus jamais l'escalier oui mais
maintenant crois moi tout peut
recommencer maintenant peut-être pour
toujours
maintenant ah oui j'oubliais où as-tu
traînait depuis six mois
non répond moi d'abord quand on lit
quand tu es parti ne tue pas parti avec
le couturier arbaud il ne faut rien
demandé pourquoi je ne veux pas de faire
souffrir je ne veux pas te mentir a donc
à me dire des choses qui pourraient me
faire mal je n'ai rien à vous est ici
même que nous sommes partis cette maison
que mathieu demandez rien alors pourquoi
aujourd'hui m'interrogerais tu ya six
mois je ne mets pas aujourd'hui les je
t'aime et parce que tu m'as et mais ici
tout seul tandis que je me débattais
avec moi même pas mais les hommes
j'aurai des comptes à rendre ça plus un
peu lui si j'ai compris moi aussi tu va
maintenant tout savoir
oui tu vas tout entendre tu vois qu'ici
même m'a fait découvrir un jour la
liberté et m'emmener dans ce pays où je
resterai comme on chante ou la vie
est-elle légère et tu n'en avais pas le
droit car tu n'étais pas un homme libre
tu parlais de mon avis tu parlais de mon
corps comme un paysan son chant tous les
hommes avec une femme sont des paysans
vous emparez vous disposez de nous et
moi je ne voulais pas que toi tu sois
comme tous ces hommes parce que toi je
t'ai aimé que je t'aime encore par
dessus tout
et cet amour éperdu pour ma personne
vous a poussé à prendre un amant
vous voyez souvent chers amis il n'est
pour rien dans notre histoire
maintenant que les célèbres ces sottises
ont peut-être plus de quoi et les
célèbres parce que deux livres que nous
connaissions est aujourd'hui chez tous
les libraires voilà tout visites les
pourrir notre histoire si des recherches
son amitié
c'est pour me souvenir de toi et vous
pensiez aussi un mois avec monsieur abu
facile je vous demande si monsieur arbon
vous aimez mieux que je ne vous ai aimés
s'il est témoin de paysans que moi je
l'aï tout de suite parce qu'il était
celui qui m'éloigner définitivement de
toi je suis resté près de lui sept jours
et aujourd'hui vous vivez seul nom
avec l'homme ou d'hélène du michigan
dont parlent les journaux
oui pourquoi
ainsi je me sens libre et qui était
prête à partir avec moi oui jacques les
uniformes scandaleuse
wacom tout empêtré des préjugés c'est
possible c'est même certain mais ce
n'est pas à mon âge
hélas qu'on peut changer de cette sorte
de préjugé
alors il n'y aurait plus d'espoir ni
pour toi ni pour moi l'espace marzelle
le chercher
oui seulement rien de ce que j'ai fait
ou n'a pu me séparer de toi jacques j'ai
voulu réserver mon avenir j'ai pas
supporté la pensée que ma vie était
bouclé par serment
parce que j'entendais respecté le
serment au pourquoi tu voulu m'enfermer
l'épousé et tu te rendrais là l'idée
demandez pas c'était magnifique
il fallait asim chiper me voler ma vie
sans me le dire
j'aurais renoncé à tous les armes au
jour le jour mais pas d'un coup à 20 ans
et tout de suite il fallait me dire tu
vois tous ces hommes sont à toi mais les
scellés bien que le monde entier
m'appartenait mais tu as referme et evra
jaloux surtout mon avenir je n'ai pas
voulu je n'ai pas pu
je te plaît moi aussi je te plains les
incapables aujourd'hui de me sacrifier
tes préjugés
jacques nous pouvons encore sortir toi
et moi toi et moi pourquoi ce qui a raté
il ya six mois réussira t-il aujourd'hui
parce qu'aujourd'hui tu as perdu jacques
parce que je suis assez désemparé pour
que ce soit passionnant d'essayer d'être
heureux tu vois
aujourd'hui j'ai plus peur de ces
portraits je voudrais au contraire
mériter ma place parmi eux mais de le
savoir que le dernier jour de ma vie et
séjours l'arjel d'honneur jacques je te
jure que je serai la femme la plus
heureuse du monde d'avoir été ta fin du
3 au soir jacques j'ai fait une grande
course inutile d'arriver devant mercedes
s'est interrogé personne
j'ai proposé à mon âge mon vieux je suis
sûr partie par le chemin du phare et là
je me suis est si tu sais que du banc de
pierre on voit encore les lumières de
l'hôtel où elle est et la juger
j'ai beaucoup réfléchi à quoi bon la
revoir je suis resté là longtemps il a
bien pensé que je ne voulais plus la
revoir v j'ai mieux respirer
je crois que je suis vraiment libéré de
cette garce un genou j'ai eu un peu de
mal à reprendre le chemin et je suis
rentré assez tranquillement
si je l'avais revue que leur ai-je dit
quand elle est seule dans ma tête
la conversation est facile mais si tout
à coup elle était là bas devant moi elle
la vraie je ne suis peut-être un certain
que je l'aurais reconnue
c'est juste pas le
on voit des êtres qu'on aimait par
dessus tout quand même encore dans son
souvenir et puis les yeux dans les yeux
on ne reconnaît pas enfin on retrouve un
détail manière on a deux nuits la
cravate ou bien une petite manie comme
ça de faire claquer longue
tu te souviens qu'il faisait ça non plus
penser je vais te dire je croise être
certain maintenant que ni toi ni moi n'y
est le cerveau et mais nous ne sommes
tous que des égoïstes
tiens-toi parlons être tu encore d'elle
aujourd'hui si elle avait couché avec
toi le premier soir et moins je ne
pensais qu'à la garder pour moi et elle
ne pensait qu'à elle mais quitte à 17
toutes ces nouvelles est bien fait il
faut plus la revoir elle ne peut plus
rien pour nous oui oui toi tu as raison
je te dis que si elle venait il faudrait
lui dire vous ne pouvez pas rester et
nous ne pouvons pas vous suivre
et si elles ne voulaient pas quand même
partir faudrait lui dire encore nous
sommes vraiment de pauvres diables sur
la terre et nous ne pouvons rien les uns
pour les autres que vous regardez
souffrir et ce n'est pas la peine
et si elle restait encore faudrait lui
dire comme dernier mot vous avez voulu
être libre et bien payé votre liberté
[Applaudissements]
la pièce que nous avons eu l'honneur de
jouer devant vous et d'armand salacrou
la mise en scène de jacques mauclair
les décors de jean pierre clech
[Applaudissements]
les costumes sont de donald cardwell
[Musique]
avec marc de rouelles dollar
michel degand
jacqueline jefford
jacques charby
gisèle casadesus
christian à leers
brigitte fossey
claude rollet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]